GOOD MORNING. WELCOME TO THE MAY
TWENTY FOUR TWENTY TWENTY TWO
ASSEMBLY. I'M SORRY MAY FOURTH
TWENTY TWENTY TWO ASSEMBLY
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE HEARING
WE WILL HAVE A HUNDRED THIRTEEN
BILLS BEFORE US TODAY TO
CONSIDER AS PART OF OUR REGULAR
ORDER HEARING BEFORE WE BEGAN I
HAVE A FEW HOUSEKEEPING NOTES TO
COVER A FIRST I'D LIKE TO THINK
ASSEMBLY MEMBERS THEY ARE TWO OF
FOR FILLING IN FOR VINCE FONG ON
THE COMMITTEE TODAY. ARE WE
ENCOURAGE THE PUBLIC TO PROVIDE
WRITTEN TESTIMONY BEFORE THE
HEARING BY VISITING THE
COMMITTEE WEBSITE AT A PRO DOT
ASSEMBLY DOT CA DOT GOV PLEASE
NOTE THAT ANY WRITTEN TESTIMONY
SUBMITTED TO THE COMMITTEE IS
CONSIDERED PULP BUT AND MAYBE
READ IT RECORD. OR REPRINTED.
ALL ARE ENCOURAGED TO WATCH THE
HEARING FROM ITS LIVE STREAM ON
THE ASSEMBLY WEBSITE. ASSEMBLY
DOT CA DOT GOV TODAY'S EVENTS.
THE HEARING ROOM WILL BE OPEN
FOR ATTENDANCE OF THIS HEARING.
THE PUBLIC MAY ALSO PARTICIPATE
IN THIS HEARING BY PHONE BY
CALLING. EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN SIX
NINE TWO. EIGHT NINE FIVE SEVEN
WITH A CONFIRMATION CODE. ONE
EIGHT FIVE ZERO ONE ONE ZERO
ZERO. THAT NUMBER IS ALSO LISTED
ON THE COMMITTEE'S WEBSITE. WE
ENCOURAGE THE PUBLIC TO MONITOR
THE COMMITTEE'S WEBSITE FOR
UPDATES. WE WILL ACCEPT PUBLIC
COMMENT ON ANY BILL PLACED ON
THE SUSPENSE FILED BY THE
COMMITTEE TODAY AND FOR WHICH
THE AUTHOR WAVES PRESENTATION
BEFORE THE CLOSE OF THE REGULAR
ORDERED HEARING. TESTIMONY ON
THESE BILLS WILL BE LIMITED TO A
STATEMENT OF NAME ORGANIZATION
DEFENDING AND POSITION ON THE
BILL. THE COMMITTEE WILL LOCK
WILL ALLOW NO MORE THAN FORTY
MINUTES OF TESTIMONY. PREFERENCE
WILL BE GIVEN TO MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC WHO ARE IN THE HEARING
ROOM- THE COVERT PANDEMIC WE
HAVE LIMITED SPACE FOR THE
PUBLIC SO PARTICIPATION. I TO
PARTICIPATE SO WE CAN ENSURE
EVERYONE MAINTAINS SIX FEET OF
SOCIAL JUSTICE. IF YOU CAME INTO
THE HEARING ROOM TODAY THE
SERGEANTS DIRECTED YOUR
ATTENTION TO THE RULES OR PUBLIC
ATTENDANCE AND PARTICIPATION
WHICH WERE POSTED OUTSIDE THE
DOOR. I ENCOURAGE MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC WHO WERE IN ATTENDANCE TO
BE AWARE OF IN OBSERVE. THOSE
RULES. PLEASE BE AWARE THAT
VIOLATIONS OF THESE RULES MAY
SUBJECT YOU TO REMOVAL OR OTHER
ENFORCEMENT PROCESSES. I WITH
THAT I'D LIKE TO ESTABLISH A
QUORUM WE HAVE ONE AND IF SO-
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. HOLDEN PRESENT. HELLO
BRIAN CALDERON GOOD IDEA DALAI.
DAVIES MY PHONE. THEY AUTO.
APRIL EDUARDO GARCIA LEVINE. FOR
UP HERE ROBERT RIVAS WEBER.
WILSON. OKAY HAVING A KORMA
STATUS REQUIREMENT LIKE TO
DISPENSE WITH THE CONSENT
CALENDAR MINUTES SECRETARY RIDGE
PLEASE READ THE DAY'S CONSENT
CALENDAR. AB SIXTEEN FORTY FOUR
FLORA AB SEVENTEEN THIRTY FOUR
BENNETT AB SEVENTEEN SIXTY EIGHT
COOPER AB EIGHTEEN FIFTY FIVE
MINS ARIAN AB NINETEEN SEVENTY
FOUR CHEN AB TWENTY FIFTEEN
COOLEY AB TWENTY ONE TWENTY NINE
CARILLO AB TWENTY ONE FORTY
EIGHT CALDERON AB TWENTY ONE
SEVENTY EIGHT BLUE. AB TWENTY
TWO SIXTEEN- IN AB TWENTY TWO
THIRTY SIX LOVE AB TWENTY TWO
SIXTY NINE GRAYSON. AB TWENTY
THREE FORTY ONE MEDINA AB TWENTY
THREE EIGHTY MAIENSCHEIN AB
TWENTY FIVE. EVAN IN AB TWENTY
FIVE EIGHTY EIGHT MAIENSCHEIN AB
TWENTY SIX EIGHTY ONE BLUE AB
TWENTY SEVEN ELEVEN CALDERON AB
TWENTY SEVEN FORTY FIVE- IN AB
TWENTY EIGHT TWENTY ONE THIS
AREA AB TWENTY EIGHT NINETEEN
NINETEEN. AB TWENTY NINE SIXTY
COMMITTEE ON JUDICIARY AB TWENTY
NINE SIXTY SIX COMMITTEE ON
NATURAL RESOURCES. SECOND
REMOVED BY THE VICE CHAIR
SECONDED BY DR QUIRK. THE
CONSENT CALENDAR IS APPROVED ON
UNANIMOUS CONSENT. LIKE TO
DISPENSED WITH THE A SUSPENSE
GALLAGHER MADAM SECRETARY WOULD
YOU PLEASE READ. AB FIFTY NINETY
FOUR TANG AB SIXTEEN SIXTY SEVEN
COOPER AB SIXTEEN SEVENTY NINE
FONG AB SIXTEEN EIGHTY ONE DALY
AB SEVENTEEN TWENTY THREE
PATTERSON AB SEVENTEEN THIRTY
ONE DAVIES AB SEVENTEEN SEVENTY
THREE PATTERSON AB SEVENTEEN
EIGHTY NINE BENNETT AB EIGHTEEN
FORTY ONE GRAYSON AB EIGHTEEN
FIFTY SEVEN CRISTINA GARCIA. AB
EIGHTEEN SIXTY SEVEN LEE AB
EIGHTEEN SIXTY EIGHT THREE OF US
AB EIGHTEEN SEVENTY TWO LOW AB
EIGHTEEN EIGHTY FIVE KALRA AB
EIGHTEEN NINETY TWO FLORA. AB
NINETEEN THIRTEEN BRIAN AB
NINETEEN TWENTY ONE JONES SAWYER
AB NINETEEN FIFTY SIX MATHIS AB
NINETEEN FIFTY EIGHT MY FONG AB
TWENTY THIRTY OUR ARAMBULA AB
TWENTY FORTY SIX MEDINA AB
TWENTY FIFTY NINE KOREA AB
TWENTY ONE OH THREE BALLOT QUE
HAN. AB TWENTY ONE THIRTEEN
ROBERT RIVAS. AB TWENTY ONE
FORTY SIX BAO QUE HAN AB TWENTY
ONE SEVENTY TWO CERVANTES AB
TWENTY ONE EIGHTY SEVEN
THREE OF US AB TWO TWO TWO TWO
REYES AB TWENTY TWO TWENTY THREE
WICKS AB TWENTY TWO THIRTY EIGHT
THREE OF US AB TWENTY TWO FIFTY.
YEAH BONTA AB TWENTY TWO FIFTY
FORMER SU CHI AB TWENTY TWO
FIFTY FIVE MIKE FONG AB TWENTY
TWO SIXTY THREE WE HAVE THE
APPROVAL AB TWENTY TWO SIXTY SIX
ON THIAGO. AB TWENTY TWO EIGHTY
SIX- IN AB TWENTY THREE TWENTY
CRISTINA GARCIA. AB TWENTY THREE
SEVENTY LEVINE AB TWENTY THREE
SEVENTY FIVE THREE OF US AB
TWENTY THREE EIGHTY TWO LEE AB
TWENTY FOUR OR ONE MCCARTY AB
TWENTY FOUR SEVENTEEN TAKING AB
TWENTY. OR TWENTY ONE BLANCA
RUBIO AB TWENTY FOUR TWENTY FIVE
BRIAN AB TWENTY FOUR TWENTY SIX
GIPSON AB TWENTY FOUR THIRTY SIX
BAO QUE HAN AB TWENTY FOUR FORTY
SEVEN LOOK IT. FOR FORTY EIGHT.
AB TWENTY FOUR SIXTY FOUR
CRISTINA GARCIA AB TWENTY FOUR
NINETY FOUR SOLIS AB TWENTY FIVE
OH ONE CORREA AB TWENTY FIVE OH
TWO. CERVANTES AB TWENTY FIVE
TWENTY GABRIEL AB TWENTY FIVE
THIRTY WOOD AB TWENTY FIVE
THIRTY EIGHT ROBERT RIVAS AB
TWENTY FIVE FORTY SEVEN THIS
AREA AB TWENTY FIVE SEVENTY DALY
AB TWENTY FIVE SEVENTY SIX AGILA
CURRY. AB TWENTY FIVE EIGHTY SIX
CRISTINA GARCIA AB TWENTY SIX
SEVENTEEN HOLDEN AB TWENTY SIX
FORTY EIGHT GRAYSON AB TWENTY
SIX SIXTY MAIENSCHEIN AB TWENTY
SIX SIXTY FIVE CORREA ABC TWENTY
SIX SEVENTY MCCARTY. AB TWENTY
SEVEN OH SIX LEVINE AB TWENTY
SEVEN SEVENTEEN WALDRON AB
TWENTY SEVEN TWENTY TWO GRAYSON
AB TWENTY SEVEN TWENTY NINE OR
DO WE JUST A BRIEF TWENTY SOME
FORTY SEVEN THIS AREA. AB TWENTY
SEVEN SIXTY ONE MCCARTY AB
TWENTY SEVEN SEVENTY NINE- IN AB
TWENTY SEVEN EIGHTY ONE
CUNNINGHAM. AB TWENTY SEVEN
EIGHTY FOUR TANG AB TWENTY EIGHT
TWENTY SEVEN QUIRK-SILVA AB
TWENTY EIGHT FORTY ONE LEFT. THE
SUSPENSE CALENDARS DEEMED
APPROVED- WE WILL MOVE NOW TO
OUR- OUR REGULARLY. SCHEDULED
HEARING OF- BILLS. OF OUR FIRST
BILL UP TODAY'S MISTER BERMAN AB
TWENTY FIVE FORTY. THE BILL
ENJOYS A DO PASS RECOMMENDATION
MOVE THE BELL. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN COLLEAGUES OVER THE
PAST DECADE CALIFORNIA ENACTED A
NUMBER OF FINANCIAL SECTOR
CONSUMER PROTECTIONS TO
SAFEGUARD RESIDENTS RECEIVING
PUBLICLY ADMINISTERED FUNDS AB
TWENTY FIVE FORTY WILL CLARIFY
THAT ACCOUNTS THAT OFFER
VOLUNTRY TIPPING MAY ALSO
RECEIVE DIRECT DEPOSITS OF
PUBLIC FUNDS WHEN CERTAIN
CONSUMER SAFEGUARDS ARE MET.
WORKING WITH BANKING COMMITTEE
STAFF WE WERE ABLE TO ADDRESS A
NUMBER OF CONCERNS FROM
OPPONENTS WE CONTINUE TO HAVE A
PRODUCTIVE DIALOGUE WITH THE
HOPE OF ADDRESSING EVEN MORE
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE
. WITH ME TODAY IS MIKE BELOW-
TO TESTIFY ON BEHALF OF JOHN.
WAS BROUGHT. ONE OF THE.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR
MICHAEL OUT ON BEHALF OF CHIME
FINANCIAL TO COMPANY CALIFORNIA
COMPANY OFFERING FEE FREE ACCESS
TO BANKING SERVICES ADDRESSING
THE PROBLEMS OF THE UNDERBANKED
AND UNBANKED WE THINK IT'S A
FAIR COMPROMISE WE CONTINUE TO
WORK WITH THE OPPOSITION WE
WOULD ASK YOUR IDOLS. THANK YOU
IS THERE ANYONE IN THE HEARING
ROOM THAT WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK IN
FAVOR OF THIS BILL. SEEING NONE
OF PHONE OPERATOR WILL TURN TO
YOU ANY MEMBER OF THE PUBLIC WHO
IS ON THE LINE I WOULD LIKE TO
SPEAK IN FAVOR OF AB TWENTY FIVE
FORTY. WE. OWNER OPERATOR. HI
IT'S ME YOUR THE PHONE OPERATOR. I'M NOT AFRAID OF MY NAME IS
ANDREA AND I'M CALLING TO
REPRESENT MILLIONS OF PRO CHOICE
WIFE ONE DEMOCRATS WHO UP. USING
OUR TAX DOLLARS TO TURN ME INTO
AN ABORTION SANCTUARY USED.
ENOUGH PROBLEMS FROM THE
PREVENTIVE. DESPITE WHAT IT
CALLED. SOMETHING TO LEARN IN
THIS JOB EVERY MOMENT. I'M WE
STILL NEED TO. I HEAR FROM THOSE
WHO ARE ON THE LINE WHO WERE.
HERE TO SPEAK ON AB TWENTY FIVE
FORTY A PHONE OPERATOR. DO WE
HAVE A PHONE OPERATOR. YES THEY
ARE WITH EIGHTY THREE. OKAY SO
WE ARE ON NORTH STREET. NO ONE
ELSE TO SPEAK IN FAVOR OKAY THEN
WE'LL COME BACK TO. MAIN WITNESS
THIS HERE AND THE COMMITTEE
HEARING ROOM- WE HAVE- DANNY
CONDO KAISER NATIONAL CONSUMER
LAW CENTER WHO IS. WE HAVE
REGISTERED A SOMEONE WHO IS
GOING TO SPEAK. IN PERSON. OTHER
ON THE PHONE LINE. OKAY PHONE
OPERATOR IF YOU CAN HE UP DANNY
CANDLE KAISER NATIONAL CONSUMER
LAW CENTER. SPEAKING OPPOSITION
DEFEAT. MARC THAT'S- YES YES
GOOD MORNING DANNY CAN'T ACROSS
ON BEHALF OF THE NATIONAL
CONSUMER LAW CENTER NCLT AND
OTHER GROUPS REMAIN IN AN OPPOSE
UNLESS AMENDED POSITION AND WE
FEEL THAT OUR PROPOSED
AMENDMENTS SIMPLY REQUIRING THE
ANY TIPS BE REFUNDED WOULD
ENSURE THAT STATE DOLLARS WHICH
THE VULNERABLE FAMILIES THERE
INTENDED TO HELP. AND WOULD
PREVENT THE STATE FROM BLESSING
THE TIPS MODEL THAT'S BEING USED
TO EVADE CALIFORNIA BLEND A LOT
AND IT'S CALLED THE FINANCIAL
HARM TO CALIFORNIANS THE
AMENDMENT DO NOT IMPACT THE
SYSTEM WHAT PHYSICAL ASPECT OF
THE BILL AND WE CONTINUE TO WORK
WITH THE ASSEMBLYMEMBER'S OFFICE
AND THE SPONSORS TO REACH. AN
AGREEMENT ON AMENDMENTS THANK
YOU. THANK YOU IS THERE ANY.
ELSE IN THE HEARING ROOM THAT
WOULD LIKE TO ADD THEIR-
OPPOSITION. SEEING ON. A PHONE
OPERATOR. WE ARE TAKING
OPPOSITION TO AB TWENTY FIVE
FORTY THAT'S- NAME. ORGANIZATION
IF ANY AND POSITION ON THE BILL. TWO NINE FORTY THREE YOUR OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. DURING THE
PEOPLE. OWNER OPERATOR WE WILL
TAKE ONLY CALLS THAT ARE ON
DEALING WITH TWENTY FIVE FORTY.
PHONE OPERATOR. YES I'M ASKING
THEM TO QUEUE UP PLEASE PRESS
ONE THEN ZERO. AND NO ONE ISSUED
A PLEASE CONTINUE TO HOLD. OKAY
SO- WILL BRING IT BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE. ARE THERE ANY
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS ON THE AB
TWENTY FIVE FORTY SEEING NONE
THIS IS OUT ON A ROLL CALL.
THANK YOU. THANK GOD- NECKS WILL
BE.
OKAY WE'RE GOING TO- SO REMEMBER
SMITH A. B. TWENTY SEVEN TWENTY
EIGHT. AND THIS ENJOY THE DO
PASSED. THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN
AND MEMBERS TODAY I'M HERE TO
PRESENT AB TWENTY SEVEN TWENTY
EIGHT MOVE THE BELL. CURRENTLY
MANY COUNTIES ARE DEALING WITH
UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCES OF
CANNABIS LEGALIZE. LEGALIZATION
AB TWENTY SEVEN TWENTY EIGHT
TAKES A STEP TO CORRECT THIS. I
LOOK FORWARD TO YOUR I VOTE AND
I HAVE A WITNESS NICOLE WORLAND
IF THERE'S ANY QUESTIONS TO BE
ASKED OKAY. I AND SHE'S ON THE
LINE YES OKAY WILL TURN TO THE
PHONE OPERATOR WE WERE LOOKING
FOR THE MAIN WITNESS ON AB
TWENTY SEVEN TWENTY EIGHT THAT
WOULD BE NICOLE FOR THE MOST. I
AM HERE THANK YOU HAVE. A GOOD
MORNING SHERMAN HOLD HOLD HOLD
NINE COMMITTEE MEMBERS MECOLE
WORLD MEN ON BEHALF OF SAN
BERNARDINO COUNTY SPONSOR OF AB
TWENTY SEVEN TWENTY EIGHT.
ILLEGAL CANNABIS FARMS THERE IS
SERIOUS GROWING THREATS ACROSS
RURAL AREAS OF CALIFORNIA AND
OVER THE LAST SEVERAL YEARS
THOUSANDS OF ILLICIT CULTIVATION
OPERATIONS. HAVE RUN RAMPANT IN
SAN BERNADINO COUNTY CENTER. THE
CURRENT UNSTRUCTURED FOR LEGAL
CULTIVATION HAVE NOT PROVEN
EFFECTIVE IN COMBATING ILLEGAL
CANNABIS MARKET. AB TWENTY SEVEN
TWENTY EIGHT REDRESS OF THE FINE
STRUCTURE FOR ILLICIT GROWTH
INCREASING THE CIVIL PENALTY TO
FURTHER DISCOURAGE ILLEGAL
CANNABIS FARMS. AS INDICATED BY
THE PCC WE ANTICIPATE COST TO
IMPLEMENT THE MEASURE WOULD BE
MINOR IN OBSERVABLE. WE URGE
COMMITTEE MEMBERS TO SUPPORT AB
TWENTY SEVEN TWENTY EIGHT. THE.
YEAH THANK YOU I ANY MEMBER FROM
THE THAT WE LIKE TO TELL. OR
GIVE THEIR NAME IN SUPPORT FOR
THIS. SAY NOT PHONE. ANYONE ON
THAT LIKE TO TELL IN SUPPORT. OF
AB TWENTY SEVEN TWENTY EIGHT.
ANYONE IN SUPPORT PLEASE PRESS
ONE THEN. ZERO ONE ZERO. AND NO
ONE HAS QUEUED UP AT THIS TIME
THANK YOU WILL BRING BACK TO THE
HEARING ROOM ANY- MEMBER OF THE
PUBLIC THAT WOULD LIKE TO TEST
TESTIFIED IN OPPOSITION. NAME
ORGANIZATION AND YOUR POSITION
OF OPPOSITION. THE OSKAR SORIANO
FROM RICHMOND CALIFORNIA AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL. THANK
YOU VERY BACK TO THE COMMITTEE
C. NO COMMENTS BILLS OUT ON A
ROLL CALL. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
MR LEE- YOU'RE PRESENTING AB
TWENTY FIFTY.
MOVE THE BILL. MISTER LABOR
COMPLEXITY THE MORNING MISTER
CHAIR MEMBERS AS DETAILED IN THE
ANALYSIS THIS BILL HAS MINOR
COST TO THE STATE AB TWENTY
FIFTY SIX DIFFERENT SPECULATIVE
SPECULATOR EVICTIONS BURKE LYING
FIVE YEARS A PROPERTY OWNERSHIP
BEFORE THE ALSO I CAN BE ABOUT
THE ALSO ACT WAS ORIGINALLY
PASSED ALLOW MOM AND POP
LANDLORDS TO LEAVE THE RENTAL
HOUSING BUSINESS WITHOUT SELLING
THE PROPERTY HOWEVER THE ELLIS
ACT HAS BEEN ABUSED BY PROPERTY
SPECULATORS REMOVE UNITS FROM
OUR. AFFORDABLE HOUSING SUPPLY
FOR PROFIT. READING OF YEAR-HOLDING PERIOD BEFORE THE ALSO I
CAN BE INVOKED ARBIL CONTINUES
RESPECT LONG TERM LANDLORDS WHO
HAVE BEEN IN THIS BUSINESS FOR
DECADES. THIS BILL BEFORE
TODAY'S A GUARDRAIL AGAINST MORE
VACATIONS AND MORE PEOPLE LOSING
THE ROOF OVER THEIR HEADS AND
ANY UP ON OUR STREETS. SPECIALLY
ASTER I VOTE AND STAY ON THE
PHONE I WILL BE JOINED SHORTLY.
BY RECALL FOX'S STAFF ATTORNEY
FOR. TENDERLOIN HOUSING CLINIC
TO PROVIDE BRIEF REMARKS AND-
ANSWERS QUESTIONS IF YOU HAVE
THEM. THANK YOU PHONE OPERATOR
WE WILL HEAR FROM ROCK HILL FOX
. IN SUPPORT OF TWENTY FIFTY.
ISSUES THAT YOU SHOULD HAVE A
OPEN LINE. BROKE RECALL FOX ARE
YOU WITH US. WE WILL MOVE ON TO
ANY OTHER ANYONE ELSE ON THE
LINE THEY WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK IN
FAVOR OF TWENTY FIFTY. HELLO
THIS IS FOR CALIFORNIA I OKAY I
WAS. WE CAN HEAR YOU PLEASE
PROCEED OKAY THANK YOU AND I
APOLOGIZE I HAD GOOD NEWS ON AND
I'M SPEAKING AWAY. BUT ANYWAY I
STRONGLY SUPPORT AB TWENTY
FIFTEEN IT'S NECESSARY IT IS
ESSENTIAL TO KEEPING PEOPLE
HOUSED I CAN TELL YOU THAT I
HAVE CLIENTS IN THE MISSION THAT
ARE JUST BEING. LITERALLY SENT
INTO HOMELESSNESS THERE IS A
BUILDING ON ALABAMA BURKE THREE
OF THE SENIORS ARE NOW HOMELESS
ONE IS HOPPING AROUND COUCH TO
COUCH AMONGST YOUR CHILDREN. THE
CHILDREN CANNOT AFFORD TO BUY
FOR THEIR MENTORS THEY CAN'T
MOVE AND ANOTHER PERSON OR THEY
THEMSELVES FACED EVICTION. WE
NEED THIS TO PRESERVE HOUSING IN
THESE PEOPLE THAT ARE BEING
TARGETED BY THE SPECULATORS ARE
THE FABRIC THE BACKBONE OF SAN
FRANCISCO THE AYE DIVERSITY TO
SAN FRANCISCO. DEAR THE
HOUSEKEEPERS THERE THE PEOPLE
WORKING- RESTAURANT AS
WAITRESSES WAITERS COOKS IN THE
BOX- JANITORS. THEY'RE NOT THIS
THEY'RE DIG NEED PEOPLE TO BE
ABLE TO LIVE IN SAN FRANCISCO.
WANT TO RETIRE AND JUMP INTO
SCHOOL AND NOT FEAR HOMELESSNESS
. IN THEIR EIGHTIES THE PEOPLE
THAT ARE BEING EVICTED ARE
TARGETED IT NEEDS. APARTMENT
BUILDINGS BY SPECULATORS WHERE
THE RED SHIRT LOW BECAUSE THEY
THE TENANTS HAVE BEEN THERE A
LONG TIME THE CONDITIONS ARE
BROAD AND INSTEAD OF ALLOWING
OTHER PEOPLE WHO TRULY WANT TO
BE. ALL MOTORS LANDLORDS. THE
SPECULATORS COME IN AND THREATEN
ALICE IT'S OUT OF THE MARKET THE
THREAT THAT NAY ALICE AND NOT
ONLY DO THEY CLEAR OUT BUILDINGS
ARE CLEARING OUT ENTIRE
COMMUNITIES AND HIGHER
NEIGHBORHOODS. THE MISSION
DISTRICT IS BEING CLANS OF THE
PEOPLE THAT MADE IT THE MISSION
DISTRICT THE LATINO FAMILIES
THAT LONG TERM WORKERS OF SAN
FRANCISCO AND THERE'S- PEOPLE
WONDERING WHY WHY ARE THERE SO
MANY HOMELESS PEOPLE IN.
CALIFORNIA WILL LOOK AT THE
RANCH LOOK AT WHAT'S HAPPENING
PEOPLE BEING EVICTED. ARE WE
NEED TO HAVE THIS AB TWENTY
FIFTY POSTO I HAVE NOTHING
FURTHER. THANK YOU I WILL NOW
MOVE TO ANY ONE ELSE WHO'S
ONLINE WHO WOULD LIKE TO
REGISTER THEIR POSITION OF
SUPPORT. I UP FOR ALL
PARTICIPANTS IF YOU WERE A
PROVIDER PLEASE PRESS ONE THE
GENERAL COLLABORATOR WILL GIVE
YOU YOUR LINE NUMBER AND HELPING
ALONG WANTED TO TALK. IN JUST
ONE MOMENT FOR OUR LINE UNDER.
HOLDING MY NUMBERS TWO YOUR LINE
IS OPEN THIS CALL. AB ONE NUMBER
SIX TWO THE Q. JUST ONE OF
CONNECT ONE NUMBER. SIXTY TWO
COME BACK UP PLEASE GO AHEAD
LINE IS UP. HOW ARE YOU GROWTH
POLISH BRAG SURVIVAL EIGHT CO
FONG THE EIGHTY TWENTY. I'M OF
THE TWENTY THOUGHT EIGHT
SEVENTEEN LOTS. HOW TOLD WOULD
BLOCK YOUR HOME DUE TO BE OUT.
WE URGE EIGHT STRONG YES I'M A.
B. CLIP. THANK YOU I WILL GO TO
ONE NUMBER SEVEN SIX UP- YES
THIS IS PAM WAYLAND- WITH THE
DILLARD'S WORDS OF. AND I
THOUGHT SO. AB TWENTY. I BELIEVE
THAT- I'M NOT SURE IF IT'S
THIRTY TWENTY FIFTH BUT FIFTY
AND MEAN IT LIVE IN PRESS
WITHOUT. TWENTY FIFTY. JOHNSON
AND I LIVE IN FOR CA. MY NAME'S
PAMELA. I CAN NOW GO ONLINE TO
SEVEN. ABOUT THE. HI THIS IT
WILL BE PARA HOW'S IT GOING. H.
SUPPORT. RIGHT NOW GO TO LINE
THE FIFTY THREE YEAR MIND UNTIL
. GOOD MORNING SHERRY MEMBERS ON
THIS FROM ALSO BEHALF OF AT WE
ARE JUST SO OF AB FIFTY THANK
YOU. JUST ONE MOMENT FOR NEXT
ONE NUMBER. LOCALI NUMBER THIRTY
EIGHT A LINE IS OPEN. OKAY MANY
MACHADO BASKETS WITH THE DELUXE
WHAT THE FONDATION I AM A VERY
VOCAL VOTER AND I PUT MY SUPPORT
BEHIND TWENTY THIRTY AND TWENTY
FOUR NINETY FOUR THIS BILL IS
SAID TWENTY FIFTY OR NOT HEARING
THOSE TWO BILLS- OPERATOR THANK
YOU. THANK YOU BUT OPERATOR
WE'RE HEARING A SUPPORT ON
TWENTY FIFTY IF THERE'S NO ONE
ELSE. TRANSFORMABLE LIFELINE TO
QUEUE UP.
WHAT'S GOING ON SEVENTY NINE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI I'M CALLING
ON BEHALF OF HOUSING NOW
COALITION HI WE ARE IN STRONG
SUPPORT. INTERNALIZE THE CUTEST
TIME OKAY WILL BRING IT BACK TO
THE HEARING ROOM- ANY ONE TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION TO AB TWENTY
FIFTY. A SUPPORT. LOW MUSKER
SORIANO NICE SUPPORT THIS BILL.
THANK YOU. ANYONE TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION. BY OPERATORS ANYONE
ONLINE I WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION TO TWENTY FIFTY. CAN
PROPOSITIONS FOR TWENTY FIFTY
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO IN JUST A
MOMENT WHILE WE GET THE DEADLINE
PROPOSITIONS. I WILL GO TO LINE
NUMBER ELEVEN. GO AHEAD YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. GOOD MORNING MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS CREAM GREASY ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF REALTORS IN
STRONG OPPOSITION RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST YOU KNOW THE THANK YOU.
FOR NOW WE'LL GO TO LINE NUMBER
SEVENTY SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. AGAIN MY NUMBER
SEVENTY SEVEN A LOT ABOUT THEM.
YES YES- IN ALLENTOWN UNION AND
I. THE KOREANS AB TWENTY FIFTY
ARE WE ARE SUPPORTING IT. ONE
ONE ONE. ANNAMALAI INC Q. THAT
ARE OPPOSED BECAUSE- WE'RE BACK
TO THE COMMITTEE SEEING NO
FURTHER COMMENT AT THIS IS THIS
BILLS OUT OF THE ROLL CALL. I
REMEMBER GOING TO HAVE A- AB
SEVENTEEN THIRTEEN TO PASS. YOUR
YOUR MICROPHONE YOUR MICROPHONE
IS NOT. MISTER CHAIRMAN FIRST
I'LL MAKE IT BRIEF AB SEVENTEEN
THIRTEEN WILL MAKE AN
INTERSECTION SAFER FOR
BICYCLISTS DRIVERS AND
PEDESTRIANS BY ALLOWING CYCLISTS
TO TREAT STOP SIGNS AS YIELD
SIGNS WHEN APPROACHING A FOUR
WAY STOP SIGN CONTROLLED
INTERSECTION ON A TWO LANE ROAD
THIS IS FOLLOWS THE DELAWARE
YIELD MODEL WHICH HAS A 23%
REDUCTION IN BY CAR COLLISIONS
IN COMPARISON TO AB TWENTY ONE
TWENTY TWO LAST YEAR WE HAVE
REMOVED MINORS- FROM FROM THE
BILL AND WE HAVE NARROWED IT TO
TWO LANE ROADS WITH SUB SECTORAL
INTERSECTIONS. THE COST ELEMENT
AT ESTIMATE FOR THIS EACH BE TO
COLLECT THE DATA AND PREPARE THE
REPORT FOR LEGISLATURE ARE MINOR
AND OBSERVABLE I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR KNIVES. DO YOU HAVE ANY
SUPPORT WITH THE SMELLS OKAY
ANYONE IN THE HEARING ROOM WOULD
LIKE TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT. OF AB
SEVENTEEN THIRTEEN. AND SUPPORT. OSCAR SORIANA SUPPORT THIS
BILL. THANK YOU A PHONE OPERATOR
WILL TAKE TESTIMONY ON THE PHONE
LINES IN SUPPORT OF SEVENTEEN
THIRTEEN. WELL THE FAULT LIES IN
FAVOR OF AB SEVENTEEN THIRTEEN
PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO ON
YOUR PHONE. AGAIN IN FAVOR OR
SUPPORT OF AB SEVENTEEN THIRTEEN
PLEASE PRESS ONE TO VERIFY OKAY
YEAH. THE GENTLEMAN THAT. OKAY
NOTHING TO APOLOGIZE PLEASE GO
AHEAD OKAY HERE IN THE HEARING
ROOM ANYONE TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION. IT'S A NON PHONE
OPERATOR WILL ENTERTAIN
OPPOSITION TO SEVENTEEN THIRTEEN
IF ANY. RIGHT NOW THE BALL ONCE
MORE OPPOSITION TO AB SEVENTEEN
THIRTEEN IT'S ONE THAT THEN
VERRALL. AGAIN OPPOSITION TO AB
SEVENTEEN THIRTEEN PLEASE PRESS
ONE THE VERITEST TIME. AND I
THINK LOOK FORWARD IT BACK.
THANK YOU BACK TO THE COMMITTEES
SAYING NO COMMENTS THAT THIS IS
OUT ON THE B. ROLL CALL THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. YEAH YOU DON'T
DAVIS BRIAN YOU'RE GOING TO BE
PRESENTING ON BOTH OF THEM ARE
ALREADY BILLS WERE HERE FIRST- A
B. TWENTY FIVE FIFTY ONE. THANK
YOU BYE. THERE ARE TECH THAT- AS
A DO PASS.
MOVE THE BILL. MORNING MR
MEMBERS THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY PRESENT THIS BILL
TODAY THE- ARMED AND PROHIBITED
PERSONS SYSTEM IS USED TO LOCATE
AND IT'S OUR PEOPLE IN OUR
COMMUNITIES THAT ARE PREVENTED
FROM OWNING FIREARMS AND
AMMUNITION IN FACT ARE ROUGHLY.
TWENTY FOUR THOUSAND FIVE
HUNDRED ARMED AND PROHIBITED
PERSONS IN THE STATE SOME OF
THESE INDIVIDUALS ARE MORE
LIKELY TO COMMIT. VIOLENCE DUE
TO REPEATED VIOLENT OFFENSES IN
THE PAST- DOMESTIC VIOLENCE AB
TWENTY FIVE FIFTY FOUR FIFTY ONE
WOULD REQUIRE THE DOJ TO NOTIFY
LAW ENFORCEMENT. WITH
JURISDICTION OF THE LAST KNOWN
ADDRESS OF AN INDIVIDUAL. IN THE
EVENT A PROHIBITED PERSON
ATTEMPTS TO PURCHASE A FIREARM
OR IN OR AMMUNITION INVOLVING
THESE LOCAL AGENCIES MORE
EFFICIENT AND COST EFFECTIVE IN
A COST EFFECTIVE WAY OF
DISARMING THESE INDIVIDUALS.
THESE RED FLAG WARNINGS ARE
CRUCIAL TO ENSURE WE KEEP DEADLY
WEAPONS IN THE HANDS OF MOST
LIKELY TO COMMIT VIOLENCE IN OUR
COMMUNITIES. ASSEMBLY MEMBER
MCCARTY RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR
IDOL. THANK YOU IS THERE ANYONE
IN THE HEARING ROOM I WOULD LIKE
TO SPEAK IN FAVOR OF. THIS BILL
TWENTY FIVE FIFTY ONE. J. NINE
PHONE OPERATOR- PUBLIC ONLINE
THAT WOULD JUSTIFY AND SUPPORT
TWENTY FIVE FIFTY ONE. THE
CURRENT PAPER OF TWENTY FIVE
FIFTY ONE PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO. AGAIN COMMENTS IN FAVOR OF
TWENTY FIVE FIFTY ONE IT'S ONE
THEN ZERO ON YOUR PHONE LINE.
AND I THINK WE LOOK FORWARD TO
THIS TIME PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HEARING ROOM ANY GOING TO SPEAK
IN OPPOSITION. TWENTY FIVE FIFTY
WOULD COME FORWARD. MUSKER
SORIANO NICE STRONGLY OPPOSES
BILL. GERMAN A MEMBER SEPARATE
IS REPRESENTING GUNS CALIFORNIA
WE'RE IN OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL
BECAUSE- THE INCREDIBLE COST
THAT HAS ALREADY BEEN INVESTED
IN THE APPS PROGRAM HAS PROVEN
THAT THE- DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE
AT THIS POINT DOES NOT HAVE THE
ABILITY TO MANAGE THAT PROGRAM
I'M SORRY IT IS JUST NAME
ORGANIZATION IN YOUR POSITION
OF. OPPOSITION WE ARE IN STRONG
OPPOSITION THIS WILL INCREASE
AND HAVE A HUGE OSTS ON THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA. THANK YOU.
IS THERE ANYONE ELSE WHO WOULD
LIKE TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION. THE
NINE WILL BRING IT BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE HERE. THAT'S OUR
THOUGHTS THE BILL IS OUT ON A
ROLL CALL. YOUR NEXT BILL IS AB
TWENTY NINE SIXTEEN. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS. THE
CALIFORNIA CONTRACTORS STATE
LICENSING BOARD IS RESPONSIBLE
FOR ADDRESSING COMPLAINTS ABOUT
CONTRACTORS NOT PUBLICLY
DISCLOSING DETAILS OF MINOR
COMPLAINTS AND LETTERS OF
ADMONISHMENT FOR ONE YEAR. AB
TWENTY NINE SIXTEEN REX EXTEND
SOME OF THE PUBLIC DISCLOSURES
FOR LETTERS OF ADMONISHMENT TO
TWO YEARS. EXTENDING THE
TIMELINE WOULD IMPROVE
TRANSPARENCY FOR CONSUMERS AND
INCREASE CONSUMER PROTECTION.
CONSUMER PROTECTION IS BEST
SERVED WHEN THE PUBLIC HAS
ACCESS TO RECORDS OF
DISCIPLINARY ACTIONS TAKEN BY
THE BOARD ADDITIONALLY THE
PUBLIC DISCLOSURE PERIOD FOR
LETTERS. OF ADMONISHMENT
SIGNIFICANTLY SHORTER THAN
ADMINISTRATIVE CITATIONS WHICH
IS FOUR YEARS. AGAIN MR MCCARTY
RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL. THANK
YOU IT. THOSE ARE ROAD SECOND IS
THERE ANYONE IN THE HEARING ROOM
IN SUPPORT OF WOULD LIKE TO
TESTIFY OR GIVE THEIR POSITION
IN SUPPORT. C. NINE WILL MOVE TO
THE PHONE LINES PHONE OPERATOR.
ANYONE ONLINE I WOULD LIKE TO
WEIGH IN IN SUPPORT. THE TWENTY
NINE SIXTEEN. HYPERCOMPLEX IN
FAVOR OF TWENTY NINE SIXTEEN
THAT'S ONE THEN THERE ON YOUR
PHONE. IN JUST ONE MOMENT
HOMEOWNERSHIP FROM LINE NUMBER
EIGHTY TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. CAN ONE NUMBER
EIGHTY TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
THANK YOU MY NAME IS SHERRY ARE
CALLED IN AND I OPPOSE THIS BILL
THANK YOU. RIGHT WILL NOW GO TO
LINE NUMBER EIGHTY NINE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. AB
ONE NUMBER EIGHTY TWO PLEASE GO
AHEAD YOUR LINE IS OPEN BY
NUMBER EIGHTY TWO. ONE EIGHTY TO
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. ALKALINE
NUMBER SEVENTY EIGHT YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING CHAIR MEMBERS MIGHT JOHN
THAT'S KEEPING THE CONTRACTORS
STATE LICENSE BOARD IN SUPPORT
THANKS SO MUCH. ALL RIGHT AND
NOW WE'LL GO TO LINE MEMBER.
WHAT LINE NUMBER NINETY TWO YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD
YOUR LINE NUMBER NINETY TWO GOOD
MORNING SKIP DHAMAADAY HALF OF
THE AMERICAN SUBCONTRACTORS
ASSOCIATION A CALIFORNIA IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY NINE
SIXTEEN THANK YOU. ELEVEN MORE
THE QUALITY OF THIS TIME PLEASE
GO AHEAD. WAY BACK FOR ANYONE IN
THE HEARING ROOM THAT WOULD LIKE
TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION. THIRTY
NINE THE PHONE OPERATOR I WILL
HEAR FROM ANYONE ON THE PHONE
LINE WHO WOULD LIKE TO REGISTER
THEIR OPPOSITION. OR CALL ONE OF
YOUR OPPOSITION TO TWENTY NINE
SIXTEEN PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO AT THIS TIME. OKAY COMMENTS
IN OPPOSITION TO TWENTY NINE
SIXTEEN THAT'S ONE ZERO. AND
THAT NOTHING TO FALL UNDER THE
SUN PLEASE GO AHEAD. WE'RE BACK
TO THE COMMITTEE THE NO COMMENTS
THEN THIS IS ON A ROLL CALL THE
COMMISSION THANK YOU. MISTER
COOPER. THE REPRESENTING ON AB
TWENTY EIGHT NINETY FOUR ENJOYS
A DO PASS. GOOD MORNING MR
CHAIRMAN VERSE- COST IMPLEMENT
AB TWENTY EIGHT NINETY FOUR THE
CONTRACTORS STATE LICENSE BOARD
OR MINOR AND AS A IN A
OBSERVABLE RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR
AYE VOTE. THANK YOU. DO WE HAVE
ANYONE IN THE HEARING ROOM THAT
WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT.
OF TWENTY NINETY FOUR. MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS MIKE WEST ON
BEHALF OF STATE BUILDING AND
CONSTRUCTION TRADES COUNCIL IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU. IF YOU ROSTER
SORIANA SUPPORT THIS BILL. THANK
YOU SEE NO OTHER WILL TURN TO
THE PHONE LINES AND WILL.
WELCOME ANYONE WHO IS ONLINE
WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT.
OF TWENTY EIGHT NINETY FOUR.
YOUR SUPPORT PLEASE PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO. NO ONE HAS QUEUED UP AT
THIS TIME. THEY WERE VERY BACK
TO THE HEARING ROOM ANYONE TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION TO REGISTER
THEIR OPPOSITION. C. NINE OVER
THE PHONE LINES. OPPOSITION ON
TWENTY EIGHT NINETY FOUR.
OPPOSITION IN TWENTY EIGHT
NINETY FOUR PLEASE PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO ONE THREE ZERO. AND
KNOWN AS EUROPE AT THIS TIME.
OKAY WE'LL BRING IT BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE. OF THIS IS GOING TO
BE OUT OF THE ROLL CALL WITH
THIS DOLLY AND MISS DAVIES
VOTING ON. THANK YOU THANK YOU.
A GOOD WORK. IF YOU LIKE TO
PRESENT YOUR BILL. YOUR PRESENT
IN AB TWENTY SIXTY CENTURIES DO
PASS.
BEEN VOTED THEIR SECOND THE ROAD
IN SECOND. PROCEED YES SIR AB
TWENTY SIXTY CHANGES THE
MEMBERSHIP OF THE MEDICAL BOARD
SUCH THAT THERE CAN BE EITHER A
EQUAL NUMBER OF. PHOSPHATE
PEOPLE OR AND DOCTORS ON THE
BOARD FOR A MAJORITY OF
LAYPEOPLE PREVIOUSLY THERE COULD
BE A MAJORITY OF- DOCTORS- THE
REASON FOR THIS BILL IS TO
ENCOURAGE THE- PEOPLE OF THE
STATE TO BETTER UNDERSTAND WHAT
THE BOARD DOES SEEM TO BE SHORT
THAT- A MAJORITY OF DOCTORS
CANNOT OVER RULE THE LAY POPLE
ON THE BOARD. BOB I HAVE
OPPOSITION ON THE LINE SHE'S WE
HAVE AN EXPERT ON THE LINE WHO
WILL SPEAK TO THE FACT THAT THAT
THIS HAS MINIMAL COST TO THE
BOARD. THANK YOU WE'RE LOOKING
FOR ERIN BONE. SHE FOR
LEGISLATION MEDICAL BOARD OF
CALIFORNIA. GOOD MORNING MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS THIS IS ERIN
BONE WITH THE MEDICAL BOARD
WE'RE PLEASED TO SPONSOR THIS
BILL AND I'M HAPPY TO REPORT
THAT THERE ARE NO COSTS TO THE
BOARD ASSOCIATED WITH IT AND- WE
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I
DON'T. VERY GOOD THANK YOU.
THERE ANYONE IN THE HEARING ROOM
THEY WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK IN
FAVOR OF THE BILL. SAY NINE WILL
GO THE PHONE LINES. ANYONE TO
REGISTER THEIR OPPOSITION TO
TWENTY SIXTY. OPPOSITION TO
TWENTY SIXTY PLEASE PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO ONE TO ZERO. I'M SORRY
I SAID. BUT SUPPORT IN ORDER TO
SHOOT UP OKAY. CONFORMAL DELTIC
OPPOSITION. MISTER CHAIRMAN A
POSITION PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO
I'M SORRY YEAH WE'RE GOING TO
TAKE IT IN THE HEARING ROOM
FIRST. PLEASE RECEIVE THIS CHAIR
MEMBERS DENIS CUEVAS ROMERO WHAT
THE CALIFORNIA MEDICAL
ASSOCIATION AND RESPECTFUL
OPPOSITION. TO THE BILL WE DO
BELIEVE THERE ARE COSTS- THAT
PANELS ARE COMPRISED OF PUBLIC
MEMBERS. MAY NOT FULLY
UNDERSTAND THE COMPLEXITIES OF
STANDARD OF CARE QUESTIONS WHICH
WILL LEAD TO- APPEALS THAT MAY
COST THE STATE. ON THE TRIAL
COURT LEVEL AND THE AG'S TO
COVER AND- REPRESENT THE MEDICAL
BOARD AT THOSE APPEALS THANK YOU
VERY MUCH THANK YOU. MUSKER
SORIANO AND I RESPECTFULLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL. THANK YOU BUT
IT THE PHONE LINES IF THERE'S NO
ONE ELSE IN THE HEARING ROOM IT
WOULD LIKE TO REGISTER THEIR
OPPOSITION. OPPOSITION ON PHONE
LINE. AND WE HAVE LINED FORTY
EIGHT- WITH. PLEASE IDENTIFY
YOURSELF I'M FORTY EIGHT. GOOD
MORNING I AM MICHELLE MONTARA
RUNNERS I AM WITH CONSUMER WATCH
JOBS WE STRONGLY SUPPORTS AB
TWENTY SIXTEEN ALONG WITH
COUNTLESS CALIFORNIA INJURED
FAMILY THANK YOU. THANK YOU. NO
ONE ELSE IS IN QUEUE AT THIS
POINT. BRING BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE. DR WEBER. GOOD
MORNING- SO I WAS WONDERING IF
MAYBE AARON BONUS COULD ADDRESS
THE CONCERNS THAT THERE WOULD BE
A COST ASSOCIATED WITH AN
INCREASE IN THE AMOUNT OF
APPEALS DONE BY THE MEDICAL
BOARD DECISIONS IF YOU NOW HAVE
PEOPLE MAKING DECISIONS ARE THE
MAJORITY OF PEOPLE MAKING
DECISIONS THAT. ARE NOT FAMILIAR
WITH THE PROFESSION OUT LET ME
JUST ADDRESS IT FIRST AND THEN
WE CAN HEAR FROM MR BOND WE ALL
SHOULDN'T COMMITTEES WERE WERE
NOT EXPERTS BUT WE LISTEN TO
STAFF AND THE PEOPLE ON THIS
BOARD ARE NOT ONLY COULD LISTEN
TO THE STAFF OF THE MEDICAL
BOARD BUT THEY WILL LISTEN TO
THE DOCTORS. AND SO. I SINCERELY
DOUBT THAT THERE'S GOING TO BE
MORE APPEALS BECAUSE OF THIS
BECAUSE PEOPLE LIKE US WILL
LISTEN TO THE EXPERTS. OUR GO
AHEAD MR ABOUT. THANK YOU- WEBER
FOR THE QUESTION- FIRST OF ALL I
WOULD RESPOND BY SAYING THAT THE
BOARD PROVIDES A TRAINING TO ALL
THOSE BOARD MEMBERS TO HELP THEM
UNDERSTAND THE DISCIPLINARY
PROCESS ITS PURPOSE THE RELEVANT
STANDARD OF CARE IN ANY GIVEN
CASE AND OTHER ITEMS THAT ARE
RELATED TO THE BOARD'S
INVESTIGATION. THE BOARD-
MEMBERS DO RELY UPON AS WELL
MEDICAL EXPERTS WHO REVIEW ALL
OF THE EVIDENCE AND RENDER AN
OPINION ON WHERE IT IS OUR IN
THIS YEAR AND CERTAINLY AS WELL
WOULD- BE ABLE TO ENJOY THE
INPUT FROM THE POSITION MEMBERS
ON- WHO ARE ALSO ON THE BOARD
AND SIT ON THESE PANELS I'D ALSO
STATE THAT THE BILL TAKES A VERY
MODEST APPROACH WE THINK TO
CHANGING THE COMPOSITION SIMPLY
REPLACING ONE PHYSICIAN MEMBER
WITH A PUBLIC MEMBER SO- I DON'T
BELIEVE THAT THERE'S GOING TO BE
ANY SIGNIFICANT DIMINISHMENT IN
THE BOYS AN INPUT. THAT POSITION
MEMBERS WOULD HAVE THERE
CERTAINLY ARE A ARE AND CONTINUE
TO BE A VERY IMPORTANT PART OF
THE BOARDS- THE DECISION MAKING
AND THEN IN AN ADDITIONALLY I
LIKE TO POINT OUT THAT THE VAST
MAJORITY OF THE BOARD CASES ARE
RESOLVED THROUGH A STIPULATION
SETTLEMENT. I THAT WAS 80% OF
OUR CASES WERE RESOLVED AND
THROUGH A STIPULATED SETTLEMENT
IN THE FISCAL YEAR NINETEEN
TWENTY. AND WHEN THAT OCCURS THE
PHYSICIAN TO ENTER INTO AN
AGREEMENT WITH THE BOARD THEY
WAIVE THEIR RIGHT. TO A JUDICIAL
APPEAL WHICH WOULD OBVIATE ANY
OF THE COSTS ASSOCIATED WITH THE
OPPOSITION'S COMMENTS. AND THEN
I THINK JUST IN CLOSING I WOULD
SAY WE'VE NOT SEEN ANY EVIDENCE
FROM THE OPPOSITION TO
SUBSTANTIATE- THEIR CLAIM THAT
THEY WOULD BE. MORE COST
ASSOCIATED IN THE MANNER THAT
THEY DESCRIBE- SO- WITH THAT I
WOULD DISAGREE WITH THOSE
COMMENTS FROM THE OPPOSITION
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR- FOR ANSWERING THOSE
QUESTIONS I- I THINK THERE IS A
DIFFERENCE WHEN YOU ARE JUDGED
BY MAJORITY OF YOUR PEERS- THAT
YOU'D BE LESS LIKELY TO APPEAL
THEN IF YOU'RE JUDGED BY PEOPLE
WHO ARE NOT NECESSARILY IN YOUR
PROFESSION- WE HAD A ROBUST
DISCUSS. IN ABOUT THIS AND
BUSINESS AND PROFESSIONS AND
THAT OF. THE SHARE OF THE
MEDICAL BOARD WAS THERE. NOW WE
WENT THROUGH THE FACT THAT
SEVENTEEN OF TWENTY OF THE
CURRENT HEALING ARTS BOARDS HAVE
LICENSED PROFESSIONALS AS THE
MAJORITY. THE FACT THAT THE
BOARD TO DO MORE THAN JUST IF
THE PLAN- WHICH IS WHY IT'S
REALLY AN IMPORTANT TO
UNDERSTAND. THE PROFESSION AND
ALL OF THE COMPLEXITY THEY ALSO
OVERSEE APPROVAL OF THE
UNDERGRADUATE AND GRADUATE
MEDICAL EDUCATION PROGRAMS ARE
CLINICAL HOSPITAL CLERKSHIPS.
ARAD ARE CONTINUING MEDICAL
EDUCATION FOR PHYSICIANS AND SO
IT'S EXTREMELY IMPORTANT THAT
YOU HAVE- PEOPLE ON THE BOARD
THE MAJORITY THE PEOPLE ON THE
BOARD THAT ACTUALLY UNDERSTAND.
BUT I THINK FOR ME WHAT WAS MOST
CONCERNING- AND YOU KIND OF.
ALLUDED TO IT. TODAY IS THAT
THIS BILL ISN'T GOING TO. CHANGE
THE OUTCOME. IT'S NOT GOING TO-
BECAUSE THERE TO BE ANY ANY
DIFFERENCE AND WHAT THE PUBLIC
HAS BEEN REQUESTING- THE FACT
THAT THIS BILL IS JUST TO KIND
OF RESTORE PUBLIC TRUST BUT
YOU'RE STILL GOING TO. YIELD AND
LISTEN TO AS YOU SAY THE
EXPERTS- IS CAN IS REALLY
CONCERNING FOR ME LIKE WE'RE NOT
IT SEEMS LIKE WE'RE JUST TRYING
TO PACIFY PEOPLE INSTEAD OF
ACTUALLY DOING SOMETHING. WHEN I
ASKED THE- THE CHAIR OF THE
BOARD SHE COULD LET ME KNOW.
WHEN HOW MANY OF THE VOTES FOR
ONE OFF SHE SHE COULDN'T BECAUSE
IT'S- CLEARLY NOT SOMETHING
THAT'S DONE ON A REGULAR BASIS
OR MAYBE EVEN NOT AT ALL. AND SO
I ABSTAINED BEFORE WILL BE
OPPOSING TODAY I DO THINK THERE
ARE SOME FINANCIAL COST THAT WE
REALLY HAVEN'T KIND OF DWELLED
INTO. BUT I THINK THAT IF WE'RE
GOING TO RESTORE PUBLIC TRUST WE
DON'T DO THAT BY REMOVING THOSE
THAT CAN BEST ADVOCATE FOR
PATIENTS BECAUSE THEY KNOW THE
PROFESSION. BUT WE DO IT BY
ACTUALLY REMOVED. IT SHOULD BE
PRACTICING IT. WE DO IT BY
CUTTING DOWN ON A TIME FRAME BUT
I DO APPRECIATE I'M BAFFERT
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. ANY OTHER
COMMENTS. ADDUCTOR WORK THIS
BILL IS OUT ON A B. ROLL CALL
WITH DOLLY DAVIES NOT VOTING AND
DR WEBBER AS A NO. VERY GOOD
THANK YOU THANK YOU. JUST OUT.
YOU'RE HERE TO PRESENT ON AB
TWENTY NINE FIFTY NINE- THIS IS
A COMMITTEE ON JUDICIARY BILL TO
PASS. THEY GIVE US A JERRY
MEMBERS THIS BILL WHICH IS. AND
MOVE TO THEIR SECOND. THANK YOU
ONE OF OUR ONGOING EFFORTS TO
CLEAN UP SOME OF THE CODES THIS
BILL SIMPLY. MAKES IT CLEAR THAT
A VICTIM OF CHILD SEXUAL ABUSE
BRINGING A CLAIM TO A PUBLIC
AGENCY NEED NOT. THE
PRESENTATION REQUIREMENT. WHICH
IS AN UNNECESSARY REQUIREMENT IN
THESE CASES. YOUR ANALYSIS
POINTS OUT THAT THERE WILL BE NO
DIFFERENCE BECAUSE BECAUSE A
REALLY WILL BE NO DIFFERENCE IN
THE NUMBER OF CASES OF BEING
BROUGHT AND I ASK THE RIGHT.
THANK YOU. IS THERE ANYONE IN
THE HEARING ROOM THAT WOULD LIKE
TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT. SYNONYMES
PHONE OPERATOR WILL TAKE SUPPORT
CALLS. TESTIMONY OR COMMENTS ON
THIS BILL. TWENTY FIVE TWENTY
NINE FIFTY NINE. IT FOR SUPPORT
FOR TWENTY NINE FIFTY NINE
PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO. LINE
EIGHTY NINE YOUR OPEN PLEASE
IDENTIFY YOURSELF. NINE EIGHTY
NINE YOUR OPEN. I SUPPORT THE
BILL.THANK YOU. NO ONE ELSE IS
A QUEUE AT THIS POINT ANYONE IN
THE HEARING ROOM THEY WOULD LIKE
TO REGISTER THEIR OPPOSITION.
IT'S A NON PHONE OPERATOR.
ANYONE ONLINE THAT WOULD LIKE TO
PRESENT THEIR OPPOSITION TO
TWENTY NINE FIFTY NINE. TWENTY
NINE FIFTY NINE OPPOSITION
PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO. ONE
ZERO. AND NO ONE HAS QUEUED UP
PLEASE CONTINUE THEY WILL BRING
IT BACK TO THE COMMITTEE. SEEING
NO QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS THIS
OUT ON A ROLL CALL. THANK YOU.
I'M IF I COULD MISS WHICH BEFORE
WE PRESENT ON YOURS- ON AB
TWENTY SIXTY QUIRK WE HAD MISS
DAVIES IS NOT VOTING. IS
BUILDING. AND OTHER PERMANENT.
IN THE BIG. OKAY BOTH THE BILL.
THIS WORKS- TWENTY SEVEN NINETY
ENJOYS A DO PASS THANK YOU GOOD
MORNING MR CHAIRMAN BERS. NOW
THIS TELLS MARK STONE OKAY I
WANT TO THANK THE COMMITTEE FOR
THEIR TIME AND CONSIDERATION OF
THIS BILL AB TWENTY SEVEN NINETY
WILL CENTER SURVIVORS. SAFETY
AND HEALTH BY MODERNIZING
CALIFORNIA'S MEDICAL MANDATING
REPORTING THE BILL WILL WILL
LIMIT THE MANDATE FOR HEALTH
PROVIDERS REPORT INJURIES TO LAW
ENFORCEMENT ONLY REQUIRE
REPORTING FOR FIRE ARM INJURIES
THIS BILL MANDATED HEALTH CARE
PROVIDERS OFFER REFERRALS TO
COMMUNITY BASED AND NATIONAL
DOMESTIC. AND SEXUAL VIOLENCE
ADVOCACY SERVICES IF THE
HEALTHCARE ROVIDER KNOWS OR
SUSPECTS THAT A PATIENT
EXPERIENCING ANY KIND OF
DOMESTIC OR SEXUAL VIOLENCE TO
BE CLEAR THIS BILL WILL NOT
AFFECT MANAGER REPORTING FOR
CHILD ABUSE OR ELDER ABUSE.
MOREOVER THIS BILL DOES NOT TAKE
AWAY THE OPTION TO REPORT TO LAW
ENFORCEMENT PATIENTS CAN STILL
MAKE REPORTS TO LAW ENFORCEMENT
OR ASK THEIR HEALTH CARE
PROVIDERS TO REPORT IF THAT IS
WHAT THEY CHOOSE. AS THE
COMMITTEE ANALYSIS STATES THERE
WILL LIKELY BE LIMITED COSTS TO
THE STATE. TESTIFYING TODAY. R.
PERLA FLORES SENIOR DIVISION
DIRECTOR FROM THE COMMUNITY
SOLUTIONS FOR BE TESTIFYING OVER
THE PHONE. AND GEN STOVER
CLINICAL LAW PROFESSOR OF LAW
AND DIRECTOR OF THE UC IRVINE
DOMESTIC LAW. CLINIC ALSO SAY WE
HAVE A LOWEST SUPPORTERS IN THIS
BILL WHO WORK IN THE DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE SPACE. IT'S SPONSORED
BY FUTURES WITHOUT VIOLENCE
ALLIANCE FOR BOYS AND MEN OF
COLOR UC IRVINE DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE LAW CLINIC. AND ENJOYS
SUPPORT FROM DOZENS OF
ORGANIZATIONS INCLUDING. THE
CALIFORNIA PARTNERSHIP TO END
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE THE LARGEST
UMBRELLA ORGANIZATION IN THE
STATE THAT WORKS ON A DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE ISSUES. THANK YOU WE'LL
TURN TO YOUR MAIN WITNESSES-
PERLA FLORES. GOOD MORNING
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE AB
2790% FOR UNIQUE AND CRITICAL
OPPORTUNITY TO INCREASE ACCESS
TO RESOURCES SAFETY AND ECONOMY
FOR SURVIVORS OF GENDER BASED
VIOLENCE MEDICAL MANDATED
REPORTER LAWS CREATE BARRIERS
FOR SURVIVOR SEEKING MEDICAL
CARE PARTICULARLY SURVIVORS FROM
UNDERSERVED COMMUNITIES SUCH A
PRODUCT AND UNDOCUMENTED
INDIVIDUALS. LIMITED THE
SPEAKERS AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMUNITY WE LIVE THE MATTER
REPORTING REQUIREMENTS OR
COURAGE PATIENCE TO BE MORE OPEN
TO DISCUSSING THEIR EXPERIENCES
WITH MEDICAL PROVIDERS. MEDICAL
MANDATE REPORTER REQUIREMENTS
ARE NOT ãUMA
NOT SURVIVOR CENTERED OR
EVIDENCE BASED THEIR MANY
EVIDENCE BASED INTERVENTIONS AND
STRATEGIES FOR ADDRESSING AND
PREVENTING DOMESTIC AND SEXUAL
VIOLENCE AND HELP SETTING. AND
MANDATORY REPORTERS ARE NOT
VIOLENT INJURIES IT'S NOT ONE OF
THEM CALIFORNIA SHOULD NOT
CONTINUE TO INVEST IN STRATEGY
THAT NOT ONLY HAS NO EVIDENCE TO
SUGGEST THAT IT REDUCES
HOMICIDES ARE SOLVED BUT THAT
ACTUALLY CREATES BARRIERS TO
HEALTHCARE ACCESS FOR SURVIVORS.
IN THE TWENTY YEARS THAT I'VE
WORKED WITH SURVIVORS OF
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE SEXUAL ASSAULT
HUMAN TRAFFICKING I'VE WITNESSED
A MUCH NEEDED SHIFT TOWARD A
COMMON FORM SURVIVOR CENTERED AN
APARTMENT BASED APPROACH AB
TWENTY SEVEN NINETY ON SURVIVOR
SAFETY. THANK CHOICE. AB TWO
SEVEN NINE FOUR. THANK YOU J.
STILLER. THANK YOU FOR THE LAST
TWO DECADES AT THE REPRESENT TO
INCLUDING BY NOT AND I'LL
COCHAIR COUNTY CONNECTED PANELS
THAT D. T. AND DIRECTING WILL BE
CENTER ON ASYLUM. AT TWENTY
NINETY IDENTIFIED HELD AT THAT'S
EXACTLY THAT. DRIVERS TAX
MEDICAL CARE ALAMEDA PLACE AND
REPORT. THREE THREE POINT. WITH
THE PRESS AND- IT IS NOT A
DIFFICULT CUTS TO POSSIBLE COST
. SECOND AB SEVEN NINETY ALLOWED
HER AND IN THE- WHICH HAD
ENORMOUS SAVING. THANK THIRTEEN
AT THE END. SUPPORTS HELPING TO
PAY. UNLIKELY WORK I HAVE BEEN
ADDED THE REPORT TONIGHT
PROFESSIONALS TYPICALLY ADULT
INTIMATE PARTNER VIOLENCE. KEVIN
ACT ON THE BACK SPEAKING NEEDED
MEDICAL CARE. ENSURING OKAY
PATIENT DISCLOSURE DOCTORS
AREN'T ABLE. TO OFFER FIFTY
DOLLARS SAID FOR MEDICAL CARE
THE DOCTOR THE. RESEARCH AND
STATE OF ONE TO FIVE AID TO OPEN
DISCUSS IN MEDICAL CARE. OUT
HERE AT THE POLICE. THE
FOURTEENTH LIKELY LITTLE IN A
THE PILOT THREE EIGHTEEN COULD
THAT ARE STILL KEY TO SAY.
THE RESEARCH REPORTING IMPACT.
THAT THE MANDATORY REPORTING
ADULT DOMESTIC VIOLENCE COULD
NOT BE CONFIRMED FIVE MINUTES
THOUGHT INSTEAD CREATES BARRIERS
TO HEALTHCARE ACCESS PROVIDE.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU IS THERE
ANYONE IN TE HEARING ROOM OF
WHAT WHICH WOULD LIKE TO
REGISTER THEIR SUPPORT. STAY NON
PHONE OPERATOR WILL TAKE SUPPORT
ON TWENTY SEVEN NINETY. IF YOU
SUPPORT TWENTY SEVEN NINETY
PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO
PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO. LINE
THIRTY TWO YEAR OPEN PLEASE
IDENTIFY YOURSELF. AND THAT ARE
QUITE ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA I THINK THAT STAGE IN
THE PARK THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
WHAT WHAT WE HAVE SWORN Q. BY
NINETY FOUR PLEASE IDENTIFY
YOURSELF YOU'RE OPEN. THANK YOU
MY NAME IS CHRISTINE MESS WITH
THE CALIFORNIA PARTNERSHIP TO
AND I THINK BACK ON IN SUPPORT.
NINE NINETY EIGHT ZERO PLEASE
IDENTIFY YOURSELF. GOOD MORNING
MY NAME IS RUTH RIVERA I'M WITH
YOU THE KIND OF WOMAN CENTER AND
WE SUPPORT THIS BILL. LIVE ONE
SIXTEEN EUROPA PLEASE IDENTIFY
YOURSELF. HELLO MISTER CHAIRMAN
NUMBER MY NAME IS MARCUS EVAN ON
BEHALF OF THE CULTURALLY
RESPONSIVE DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
NETWORK IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
LIKE ONE HUNDRED YEAR OPEN
PLEASE IDENTIFY YOURSELF. AT THE
STATE BANNER TACKLING FROM
TEACHERS ABOUT SILENCE AND I AM
IN STRONG SUPPORT IN THAT BATTLE
. LINE EIGHTY NINE YOUR OPEN
PLEASE IDENTIFY YOURSELF. THE
CARD OPPOSE. RIGHT ONE TWO ZERO
ZERO PLEASE IDENTIFY YOURSELF.
HELLO MY NAME IS ANNE TOLLEY AND
I'M CALLING FROM FUTURES WITHOUT
VIOLENCE IN SUPPORT OF THE CELL
. IT WAS SPEAKERS NO ONE ELSE
WAS IN QUEUE PLEASE CONTINUE
THEY WILL COME BACK TO THE
HEARING ROOM. ANYONE TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION. MAX GREAT WITH
LIBERTY BAPTIST CHURCH IN
LIBERTY LIFE CENTER I OPPOSE THE
BILL.
MY NAME IS SHANE KENNY AND I
OPPOSE THIS BILL. MY NAME IS
LAUREN WITH- I OPPOSE THIS BILL
. DO I NEED LOWER. MY NAME IS
VERONICA AND I OPPOSED TO AB
TWENTY SEVEN NINETY. ELIZABETH
KENNY I OPPOSE THIS BILL. THAT'S
YOUR JAMES COOK LEVELS BAPTIST
CHURCH IN CONCORD CALIFORNIA I
ALSO REPRESENT PROJECT TRUTH- I
OPPOSE THIS BILL. MY NAME IS
DENISE ARE YOU ARE CO FOUNDER
FREEDOM ANGELS AND I OPPOSE THIS
BILL. TARA THORNTON CO FOUNDER
BILL. MY NAME IS JULIA STILES
AND I OPPOSE AB TWENTY SEVEN
NINETY. MAX GRAVES LIBERTY
BAPTIST CHURCH THE PASTOR AND
ALSO A REPRESENT LIBERTY LIFE
CENTER AND I OPPOSE THIS BILL.
LARRY **** WITH FIRST BAPTIST
CHURCH AND- THE PRINCIPAL FINER
POINT CHRISTIAN ACADEMY. AND OUR
CHURCH AND OUR SCHOOL OPPOSE
THIS BILL. MOSCOW SORIANO AND AS
A PROUD DEMOCRAT I OPPOSE THIS
BILL. AND PASTOR TENDON AFIELD
REPRESENTING A CORNERSTONE
BAPTIST CHURCH MODESTO AND ALSO
A GRASSROOTS ORGANIZATION KNOWN
AS TAKE A STAND STANISLAUS ON
OPPOSING THIS BILL. MY NAME IS
ERIN JASPER WITH LIBERTY BAPTIST
ACADEMY AND I OPPOSE THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS SUSAN AREN'T ALL I'M
WITH THE RIGHT TO LIFE LEAGUE
AND I OPPOSE THIS BILL. AB
TWENTY SEVEN NINETY. MY NAME IS
SHAWNA WILLIAMS I'M WITH CALVARY
CHAPEL CHURCH AND I OPPOSE THIS
BILL.MY NAME IS VANESSA SANTOS
AND I OPPOSE THIS BILL. MY NAME
IS KATIE SCHERMAN AND I OPPOSE
THIS BILL. HELLO MY NAME'S DIANA
TO CANADA OPPOSE AB TWENTY SEVEN
NINETY. THANK YOU SEE YOU KNOW
OTHERS WILL TURN TO THE PHONE
LINES PHONE OPERATOR WE WILL
HEAR- TEST WILL HAVE A COMMENT-
IN OPPOSITION TO AB TWENTY SEVEN
NINETY NAME ORGANIZATION AND
POSITION OF OPPOSITION. THE
PROPOSITION PLEASE PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO. RIGHT ONE ZERO NINE
YOUR OPEN PLEASE IDENTIFY
YOURSELF. HELP ME I OPPOSE. THEY
SELL. LINE ONE ONE ZERO YOUR
OPEN PLEASE IDENTIFY YOURSELF.
GABRIELLE IN GRANDSTAND AT
SACRAMENTO COUNTY WE OPPOSE THIS
BILL. LINE ONE ONE TWELVE EUROPE
IT PLEASES IDENTIFY YOURSELF.
LIKE WHAT WHAT TO YOU ARE OPEN.
RIGHT ONE SEVENTEEN EUROPA
PLEASE IDENTIFY YOURSELF. GOOD
MORNING COMMITTEE CHAIR AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS I AM ELAINE
CALLING ON BEHALF OF SAN DIEGO
COUNTY DISTRICT ATTORNEY SUMMER
STEPHAN WE ARE IN STRONG
OPPOSITION AB TWO SEVEN NINE
ZERO THANK YOU. RIGHT ONE TWO
THREE YOUR OPEN PLEASE IDENTIFY
YOURSELF. HI MY NAME IS APRIL
NINTH WILL BE FROM RIVERSIDE
COUNTY AND I OPPOSE THIS BILL.
NO I'M GOOD NINE SIX FOR YOUR
OPEN MIND SIX BEFORE YOU OPEN
PLEASE IDENTIFY YEAH. WHAT'S
YOUR MIND SIXTY FOR YOUR OPEN.
HI THIS IS MANDY HOW OPEN FROM
SEVEN IN ACCOUNTING AND I OPPOSE
THIS BILL. NINE EIGHTY TWO YOUR
OPEN PLEASE IDENTIFY YOURSELF.
GOOD MORNING MEMBERS HALF OF
CARICATURES BY DIET AND LYFT
MATTERS MY NAME IS TERRY HAD
CALLED ME AND WE ARE IN STRONG
OPPOSITION OF THE BILL THANK YOU
. NINE EIGHTY FIVE YEAR OLD
COULD PLEASE IDENTIFY YOURSELF.
HI IS RACHEL HANDLE WITH NEXT
WITH YOUR FOR FREE AND WE AT THE
BILL. NINE EIGHTY EIGHT EUROPA
PLEASE IDENTIFY YOURSELF. HI MY
NAME IS THERE AVAILABLE IT'S
LIKE THAT AND I OPPOSE THIS BILL. NINE EIGHTY NINE EUROPA PLEASE
IDENTIFY YOURSELF. AB TWENTY
SEVEN NINETY IS TRASH SUPPOSED.
WE HAVE ONE MORE IN Q. I HAVE A
NUMBER FOR YOU IN A MOMENT. MY
TWELVE YEAR OPEN PLEASE IDENTIFY
YOURSELF. IT IS DANIEL WITH THAT
LEG IN FRESNO AND WE OPPOSE THIS
BILL. AND SPEAKERS NO ONE ELSE
IS IN QUEUE PLEASE CONTINUE
THANK YOU WILL BRING IT BACK TO
THE COMMITTEE. SEEING NO
COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS FROM THE
COMMITTEE THIS BILL IS OUT ON A.
B. ROLL CALL WITH WEBER NOT
VOTING. THANK YOU YOU. RESTORED
YOUR PRESENT AB TWENTY ONE
NINETY FOUR ENJOYS A DO PASS.
BEEN MOVED AND SECONDED. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS AB
TWENTY ONE NINETY FOUR REQUIRES
PHARMACISTS AND PHARMACY
TECHNICIANS TO HAVE ONE HOUR OF
CONTINUING EDUCATION THAT
PROVIDES CULTURALLY COMPETENT
CARE TO MEMBERS OF THE LGBTQ
COMMUNITY THIS BILL WILL HELP
PHARMACISTS ADDRESS HEALTH
DISPARITIES AND PROVIDE SPECIFIC
SUPPORT FOR THE SPECIAL NEEDS OF
THIS COMMUNITY IN CALIFORNIA I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST- I VOTE ON
AB TWENTY ONE NINETY FOUR. THANK
YOU IS THERE ANYONE IN A
COMMITTEE HEARING ROOM THAT
WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK OR REGISTER
THEIR SUPPORT. THEY NINE PHONE
OPERATOR WE'RE HEARING FOR
SUPPORT ON AB. TWENTY ONE NINETY
FOUR. SUPPORT FOR A BI. PLEASE
PRESS ONE ZERO. FIND TWENTY
THREE YEAR OLD WITH PLEASE
IDENTIFY YOURSELF. ONE MOMENT.
MY TWENTY THREE YEAR OPEN PLEASE
IDENTIFY YOURSELF. MICHELLE
RIVAS WHAT THE CALIFORNIA
PHARMACISTS ASSOCIATION
COSPONSORING SUPPORT. AND NO ONE
ELSE IS A QUEUE AT THIS TIME
PLEASE CONTINUE THANK YOU WILL
COME BACK TO THE HEARING ROOM
WE'LL HEAR FROM OPPOSITION. NAME
ORGANIZATION A POSITION OF
OPPOSITION. OSCAR SORIANO POSES
BILL. MAX GRAVES LIBERTY BAPTIST
CHURCH WILL BE LIFE CENTER I
OPPOSE THIS BILL SODOMY IS A
VIOLATION OF GOD'S LAW. I SEE NO
OTHER WILL TURN TO THE PHONE
OPERATOR PHONE OPERATOR-
POSITION OF OPPOSITION ON TWENTY
ONE NINETY FOUR. OPPOSITION FOR
TWENTY ONE NINETY FOUR PLEASE
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO. LINE EIGHTY
EIGHT YOU'RE OPEN PLEASE
IDENTIFY YOURSELF. HI MY NAME IS
THERE A DELAY ON WITH LIKE THAT
NIGHT BECAUSE IT'S NOW. RIGHT AB
TWO EUROPA PLEASE IDENTIFY
YOURSELF. GOOD MORNING ON BEHALF
OF CALVARY BY FAILURE CHURCH AND
FREEDOM LIFE MATTERS KERRY
ACCORDION WE ARE IN STRONG
OPPOSITION OF THE TWENTY ONE
NINETY FOUR. LIKE TWENTY SIX
YEAR OPEN PLEASE IDENTIFY
YOURSELF. HI. HELLO HELLO WE CAN
HEAR YOU YEAH SURE- OPEN. YES WE
- AND I OPPOSE. TWENTY ONE ONE
FOURTEEN. THIS BILL IS TWENTY
ONE NINETY FOUR WERE ONLY TAKING
TESTIMONY ON TWENTY ONE NINETY
FOUR. WHAT- THREE OPEN PLEASE
IDENTIFY YOURSELF. YES HELLO
THIS IS VERY NEGATIVE NOT AT L.
A. COUNTY AND I OPPOSE THIS BILL. LIVE ONE ONE ZERO YOUR OPEN
PLEASE IDENTIFY YOURSELF.
GABRIELLE INGRAM SACRAMENTO
COUNTY AYE OPPOSED TO STILL. MY
TWELVE YEAR OPEN PLEASE IDENTIFY
YOURSELF. DANIEL PROGRESS NO AND
I DON'T. NINE SIXTY FOR YOUR
OPEN PLEASE IDENTIFY YOURSELF.
YES THIS IS MARY HOLDEN
CONCERNING OF COUNTY AND I
OPPOSE AB TWENTY ONE NINETY
FOUR. STE STE. NINE EIGHTY NINE
YOUR OPEN PLEASE IDENTIFY
YOURSELF. AB TWENTY ONE NINETY
FOUR IS ALSO TRAVIS OPPOSE. MY
NINETY SEVEN YEAR OPEN PLEASE
IDENTIFY YOURSELF. HELLO MY NAME
IS PAMELA BERET AND I OPPOSE AB
TWENTY ONE NINETY FOUR. AND
THERE IS NO ONE ELSE SECU PLEASE
CONTINUE. THEY WILL BRING BACK
TO THE COMMITTEE. THE SAYING NO
COMMENTS OKAY YES. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIRMAN I WANT TO THANK
THE AUTHOR FOR BRINGING THIS
IMPORTANT BILL TO OUR COMMITTEE
INTO MOVING IT FORWARD IN THE
LEGISLATURE HAS THE- A STRONG
ALLY TO THE LGBTQ PLUS COMMUNITY
I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT THAT WE
HAVE CULTURAL COMPETENCY WHEN IT
COMES TO THE- NOTE. ALL THE
VARIOUS DIFFERENT ISSUES RELATED
TO THE NEEDS AND RESOURCE IT BUT
MOST IMPORTANTLY TO THE HEALTH
AND WELL BEING OF OUR COMMUNITY
AND I ESPECIALLY WANT TO THANK
YOUR SPONSORS. THE CALIFORNIA
PHARMACISTS ASSOCIATION THE
QUALITY CALIFORNIA AND FOR MY
OWN BACKYARD INTO THE LOS
ANGELES MEMBERS THAT I
REPRESENTS THE L. G. B. T. Q.
FAMILIES IN MY DISTRICT. THE LOS
ANGELES LGBT CENTER SO THANK YOU
SO MUCH FOR BRINGING THIS BILL
FORWARD I'M SO HONORED AND PROUD
TO BE ABLE TO VOTE FOR IT TODAY
THANK YOU. THANK YOU SO. WHERE
WOULD YOU LIKE TO OF CLOSING
COMMENTS. I RESPECTFULLY REQUEST
RIVA. IT'S OUT ON THE IT THE
BILL IS OUT REPUBLICANS NOT
VOTING DAVIS I. LET'S SEE WILL
TURN TO. RIVAS LIKE PRESENT.
RECEIVING YOUR TESTIMONY I HEAR
PERCENT PRESENTATION OF AB
TWENTY NINETY FOUR AND ENJOYS A
DO PASS. HELLO NO. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIRMAN AND COLLEAGUES
IT'S OF THIS LEGISLATION SENATE
BILL TWO ZERO NINE FOUR SIX
REQUIRE LOCAL JURISDICTIONS TO
REPORT THEIR PROGRESS TOWARD THE
BILL- THE BUILDING OF EXTREMELY
LOW INCOME OR YELL I UNITS TO
STATE OFFICIALS AS PART OF THEIR
pTHIS BILL SPECIFICALLY WOULD
SEPARATE THE EXTREMELY LOW
INCOME CATEGORY AND A VERY LOW
INCOME HOUSING CATEGORY IN THE
ANNUAL PLAN PROCESS A LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS AND OUR STATE WILL
HAVE. A CLEAR UNDERSTANDING OF
HOUSING NEEDS AND ALLOW OUR
STATE TO BETTER IDENTIFY FINDING
A POLICY OPPORTUNITIES FOR OUR
MOST VULNERABLE FAMILIES IN THE
EXTREMELY LOW INCOME- CATEGORY.
THIS BILL HAS. A NEGLIGIBLE
FISCAL IMPACT WITH ME TO TESTIFY
IS GLOSSY ELECTROSTEEL- CLINGS
ON BEHALF OF ALL HOME THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TESTIMONY.
MISTER CHAIRMAN MEMBERS GOOD
MORNING THAT'S THE LEGACY OF
CRANKS HERE WE HAVE A HOME THIS
IS A VERY IMPORTANT BILL IN
ORDER TO ENSURE THAT WE ARE
FULLY ACCOUNTING FOR THE PEOPLE
THAT ARE IN EXTREMELY LOW INCOME
CATEGORY AND MAKE SURE THAT WE
PREVENT PEOPLE FROM ACTUALLY
SLIDING INTO HOMELESSNESS WE
HAVE. THE CONSIDERATION OF THE
COMMITTEE AND RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR I. PHONE. THANK YOU IS
THERE ANYONE IN THE HEARING ROOM
THAT WOULD LIKE TO. LEND THEIR
SUPPORT. FOR A BI TWENTY NINETY
FOUR. SAY NONE WILL GO TO THE
PHONE LINES PHONE OPERATOR WERE
ENTERTAINING SUPPORT FOR TWENTY
NINETY FOUR. YEAH YOU DOING THE
TO START SUPPORT FOR TWENTY NINE
NINETY FOUR PLEASE PRESS ONE
ZERO FOR SUPPORT PRESS ONE TWO
ZERO. OKAY RIGHT. RSL'S GET THE
NUMBER. NO ONE IS QUEUED UP AT
THIS POINT BACK TO THE HEARING
ROOM WILL HER FOR OPPOSITION.
MAX GRAVELY BAPTIST CHURCH LIVE
LIFE CENTER THIS BILL IS
WRITTEN. FROM A PRESUPPOSITION
OF TERRIBLE ECONOMIC POLICY AYE
OPPOSED THE BILL. HI I'M DIANA
TO CANADA POST THIS BILL MANY
RIVAS BILL I OPPOSE PLEASE. BUT
LET ME JUST BE VERY CLEAR EVEN
THAT IS NOT GOING TO BE
TOLERATED WE HAVE THE CORPSMAN
MISSILE IN THIS HEARING WHO WILL
RESPECT YOU AND YOU RESPECT THE
AUTHOR IN THIS COMMITTEE. THANK
YOU. OKAY WE'RE VERY CLOSE JAMES
COOK HOUSE BAPTIST CONCORD AND
REPRESENTS PRO LIFE- MANY
MINISTRIES- I OPPOSE THIS BILL.
THEY WILL GO TO THE PHONE LINES
. OPPOSITION. YOUR OPPOSE PLEASE
PRESS ONE ZERO PLEASE PRESS ONE
ZERO. LINE EIGHTY TWO YEAR OPEN
. GOOD MORNING ON BEHALF OF ROCK
COVER CHARGE AND TEMPERATURES I
YEAH YEAH AND LYFT MATTERS MANY
MILITARY HAVE PROBLEM WE ARE AN
ABSOLUTE OPPOSITION AT THIS TIME. NINE SIXTY FOR YOUR OPEN
PLEASE IDENTIFY YOURSELF. AND
GET THIS MAN A HOAGLAND
CONTROVERSIAL COUNTY AND I
OPPOSE THIS BILL. ONE SEVENTY
FIVE YEAR OPEN PLEASE IDENTIFY
YOURSELF. NINE SEVEN FIVE YEAR
OPEN SEVENTY FIVE. HELENE WALL
FIBROSIS BILL. IN SPEAKERS NO
ONE ELSE IS GOING TO AT THIS
POINT PLEASE CONTINUE. READ IT
BACK TO THE COMMITTEE. YOU KNOW
COMMENTS IT'S OUT ON A ROLL CALL
. YOU'RE GOING TO ALSO PRESENT-
I BELIEVE. CRISTINA GARCIA THIS
BILL YES THE MOBILE TWO ZERO
ZERO FOUR. THE BILL TWO ZERO
ZERO FOUR THAT HAS A TO PASS- ON
BEHALF OF THE SALE NUMBER GARCIA
OF THIS LEGISLATION WILL ENSURE
THAT UNDOCUMENTED YOUTH WHO
OBTAIN A CALIFORNIA DREAM LOAN
ARE PROVIDED CRITICAL RESOURCES
BOUT THE ATTAINMENT. REPAYMENT
AND RELIEF OPTIONS AVAILABLE TO
THEM AS A BORROWER AMONG OTHER
INFORMATION THERE WILL BE A
MINOR COSTS TO THE CSU AND UC
SYSTEMS TO ADD THE ADDITIONAL
REPORTING AN EXIT COUNSELING
WITH ME HERE TESTIFIED THIS
MORNING IN SUPPORT IS CHRIS
SANCHEZ WITH THE WESTERN CENTER
ON LAW AND POVERTY THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR. THANK YOU THIS PER
SE THE MORNING MESSAGE REMEMBER
CHRIS RESPONSE SAYS POLICY
ADVOCATE THE WESTERN CENTER ON
LAW AND POVERTY WERE PROUD TO BE
A CO SPONSOR THE SPELL BIGGER
THE NOW SAYS THE COSTS ARE
MINOR- AND THE BILL WOULD JUST
STRAIGHTEN THE CALIFORNIA DREAM
ON. THANK YOU MISTER THANK YOU
IS THERE ANYONE ELSE IN THE
HEARING ROOM IT WOULD LIKE TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT. GOOD MORNING
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS REDEEM
MEDINA. ON BEHALF OF COALITION
FOR HUMANE IMMIGRANT RIGHTS
CHAIRED THAT PROUD CO SPONSOR
THANK YOU THANK YOU. WHEN I
WOULD MOVE TO THE PHONE LINES
FOR SUPPORT ON AB TWENTY TWO
ZERO ZERO FOUR. FORT PLEASE
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO ONE THEN
ZERO LINE ONE FOR YOUR OPEN.
GOOD MORNING KATRINA LYNDON ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
UNDOCUMENTED HIGHER EDUCATION
COLLISION IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
AB TWO ZERO ZERO FOUR THANK YOU
. AND SPEAKERS NO ONE ELSE WAS
IN QUEUE AT THIS POINT THEY WILL
COME BACK TO THE HEARING ROOM
OPPOSITION TO AB TWO ZERO ZERO
FOUR. MUSKER SORIANO AFTER
LOOKING DEEPLY INTO THIS BILL I
OPPOSE IT.
HELLO DIANA TO CAN I OPPOSE THIS
BILL. SO YOU KNOW WHETHER TO-
WHEN THEIR OPPOSITION I WILL
MOVE TO THE PHONE LINES.
OPPOSITION ON TWO ZERO ZERO FOUR
. GIVEN OPPOSITION IN TWO ZERO
ZERO FOUR PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO. LINE EIGHTY NINE YOUR OPEN. I LIVE IN THE SOUTH AND AYE
OPPOSED AB TWO THOUSAND FOR DEBT
IS BAD. AND WE HAVE. AB TWO YOUR
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HEROTOPIA
AND I OPPOSE THIS BILL. AND I
HAVE ONE MORE IN Q. ONE MOMENT.
ONE MOMENT.
NINE ONE FOUR NINE YOUR OPEN
PLEASE IDENTIFY YOURSELF. HI MY
NAME IS LYNETTE GONZALEZ AND AYE
OPPOSED TO SELL. IT'S NOT. NO
ONE ELSE IS GOING TO AT THIS
POINT OKAY WE BRING BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE. C. NO COMMENTS WE
WOULD THIS BILL IS OUTWITH
REPUBLICANS NOT VOTING DAVIES I. MISSISSIPPI ARE TO. SB
SEVENTEEN ELEVEN RESIDUE PASS.
THE MOVE TO THEIR SECOND. THANK
YOU ON A WHEELCHAIR- AB HERE TO
PRESENT AB SEVENTEEN ELEVEN AB
SEVENTEEN ELEVEN IS A SIMPLE
CLARIFICATION BILL WHEN IT COMES
TO PUBLIC NOTIFICATIONS OF DATA
BREACHES IN GOVERNMENT SYSTEMS.
WHILE THE LAW IS CLEAR IN
SITUATIONS WHERE ONLY ONE PARTY
IS IN CONTROL OF THE SYSTEM LIKE
A GOVERNMENT DEPARTMENT OR A
PRIVATE BUSINESS. THE CURRENT
LAWS VAGUE WHEN COMPANIES
WORKING WITH GOVERNMENT SYSTEMS
SUFFER A DATA BREACH IN THESE
INSTANCES THE LAW TREATS THESE
DATA BREACHES LIKE PRIVATE
BUSINESS BRIDGES WITHOUT ANY
CONNECTION TO THE GOVERNMENT
SYSTEM. THIS METHOD OF REPORTING
DOES NOT INFORM THE PUBLIC THAT
THEIR INFORMATION WAS HANDLED BY
A THIRD PARTY. IN A TIME WHEN
PHISHING SCAMS AND FAKE
NOTIFICATIONS ARE PREVAILING IT
IS IMPORTANT TO PROVIDE
REFERENCES FOR THE PUBLIC TO
DOUBLE CHECK NOTICES TO ENSURE
AUTHENTICITY. IT'S
UNDERSTANDABLE CONSIDERING THAT
THESE NOTIFICATIONS MAY COME
FROM A COMPANY THAT IS A THIRD
PARTY CONTRACTOR AND THE
INDIVIDUAL HAS NEVER EVEN HEARD.
THERE HAD ANY INTERACTION WITH
THAT COMPANY. AB SEVENTEEN
ELEVEN ALSO REQUIRE GOVERNMENT
AGENCIES TO REPORT DATA BREACHES
OF ENTITIES WHO ARE WORKING ON
OR WITH GOVERNMENT SYSTEMS IN
ADDITION TO REPORTS POSTED BY
WITH OUR BY THOSE ENTITIES. THIS
WILL PROVIDE THE PUBLIC WITH A
MORE INFORMED UNDERSTANDING
CLARITY OF HOW THEIR INFORMATION
IS HANDLED AND ALLOW THEM TO
RESPOND ACCORDINGLY. ASK FOR AYE
VOTE THANK YOU THANK YOU IS
THERE ANYONE IN THE HEARING ROOM
THAT WOULD LIKE TO REGISTER
THEIR SUPPORT. OR AB SEVENTEEN
I'M SORRY HAVING SEVENTEEN
ELEVEN. OSKAR SORIANO AND I
SUPPORT THIS BILL. SHY AND KENNY
I SUPPORT THIS BILL. JERRY BROWN
I GUESS OVERNIGHT SUPPORT AB
SEVENTEEN ELEVEN. DINI SECULAR
IN SUPPORT. HER THORNTON CO
FOUNDER FREEDOM ANGELS OF LAND
STRONG SUPPORT. THERE'S A THEIR
ADDRESSES AND- CONNIE I SUPPORT
THIS BILL. ELIZABETH KENNY I
SUPPORT THIS BILL. LARA- I
SUPPORT THIS BILL. SHOELESS
CHILD SUPPORT AB ONE SEVEN ONE
ONE. MY NAME IS VANESSA SANTOS
THE NIGHT SUPPORT AB ONE SEVEN
ONE ONE. KATIE'S GOT MAN I
SUPPORT AB SEVENTEEN ELEVEN.
THANK YOU SEEN OTHERS AND
SUPPORT REMOTE TO THE PHONE
LINES PHONE OPERATOR SUPPORT AND
SEVENTEEN ELEVEN. IF YOU SUPPORT
SEVENTEEN ELEVEN PLEASE PRESS
ONE ZERO. WHAT'S IN A FEW
SUPPORT PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO.
GLIDE ONE ONE ZERO YOUR OPEN
PLEASE IDENTIFY YOURSELF.
GABRIELLE IN GRANDSTAND AT
SACRAMENTO COUNTY WE SUPPORT. MY
TWELVE YEAR OPEN PLEASE IDENTIFY
YOURSELF. DANIEL FROM FRESNO
COUNTY AND- WE SUPPORT BILL.
NINE ONE FIFTY OPEN PLEASE
IDENTIFY YOURSELF. I CAN HEAR ME
YES. REYES RODRIGUEZ A PHONE
LINES OPEN MY NAME IS YOU KNOW
WATCHING CLIMB FROM PROJECT
PLANNING THAT REPRESENT YOU YOU
PROBABLY RUNNING FOR U. S.
SENATE IN HEARING WRONG.
FAVORITE THIS POST. I WE WERE
EARNING YOU VERY MUCH ATHENEX
ANCHOR PLEASE. THANK YOU. BY
WHAT WERE FIVE SEVEN YOURSELF.
SO I WENT FIVE ONE IS THAT THE
BY. TELL BEING DIEGO I SUPPORT
THIS BILL. IS THERE ANYONE ELSE
ON OPERATORS AT THE LAST BIGGER
IN SUPPORT AND ONE THREE THREE
OPEN. SEVENTY DEGREES WITH
PAKISTAN TENNIS BOB AND WE
SUPPORT THE FELL. FIVE ONE FIVE
SIX ZERO PLEASE IDENTIFY
YOURSELF. HI MY NAME IS LYNETTE
GONZALEZ AND I AM IN ORDER TO
SELL. RIGHT EIGHTY TWO YEAR OPEN
PLEASE IDENTIFY YOURSELF. THANK
YOU CARRY A CALL BEYOND STANDING
AND WATCHING I AM I STRONGLY
SUPPORT AB ONE SEVEN ONE ONE. MY
EIGHTY FIVE YEAR OPEN PLEASE
IDENTIFY YOURSELF. HI THIS IS
RACHEL CANNOT. YOU CAN MEET EVEN
DEEPER FREEDOM AND WE SUPPORT
THAT FELL. LINE EIGHTY EIGHT
YOUR OPEN PLEASE IDENTIFY
YOURSELF. YOUR ABILITY ON
SEVERINO COUNTY AND I SUPPORT
THE BILL. NINE EIGHTY NINE YEAR
OPEN PLEASE IDENTIFY YOURSELF. I
SUPPORT SEVENTEEN ELEVEN. NINE
ONE FOUR TWO YEAR OPEN PLEASE
IDENTIFY YOURSELF. ONE FOUR TWO
YOU ARE OPEN- I'M SORRY THAT WAS
ME- MY NAME IS TERRA I'M IN
ALAMEDA COUNTY AND I STRONGLY
SUPPORT THE BILL. IN SPEAKERS
THERE'S NO ONE ELSE THE QUEUE
NOW PLEASE CONTINUE. THEY WILL
TURN TO THE HEARING ROOM FOR
OPPOSITION. SAY NONE PHONE
OPERATOR OPPOSITION TO AB.
SEVENTEEN ELEVEN. RESISTANT TO
SEVENTEEN ELEVEN PLEASE PRESS
ONE ZERO PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO.
NO ONE IS QUEUED UP AT THIS
POINT I THANK YOU VERY BACK TO
THE COMMITTEE. OF THE BILL IS
OUT ON A ROLL CALL. I MISS
WILSON. LAST PRESENTER FOR THE
DAY WELL TWENTY EIGHT SIXTY
THREE. THE PASS.
GOOD MORNING MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE IT IS MY
GREATEST PLEASURE IS THIS MY
FIRST TIME PRESENTING BEFORE
COMMITTEE- TO PRESENT IS SIMPLY
BILL TWENTY EIGHT SIXTY THREE
AND FRONT OF YOU TODAY AB TWENTY
EIGHT SIXTY THREE WILL REQUIRE
THE DEPARTMENT OF HOUSING AND
COMMUNITY DEVELOPMENT TO PROPOSE
MANDATORY BIKE PARKING STANDARDS
AND MULTI FAMILY RESIDENTIAL
BUILDINGS AND THE CALIFORNIA
BUILDING STANDARDS COMMISSION TO
UPDATE EXISTING BICYCLE PARKING
STANDARDS AND NON RESIDENTIAL
BUILDINGS. BECAUSE THESE UPDATES
ARE BEING MANDATED TO IT AT THE
NEXT TRAINING- UP THE COSTS
ASSOCIATED WITH THIS BILL ARE
CONSIDERED MINOR AN OBSERVABLE
THIS BILL HAS NO KNOWN
OPPOSITION THANK YOU AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE ON THIS MEASURE MCGILL IT'S
BEEN VOTE. THEY'RE GONNA BY DR
ROBERT. IS THERE ANYONE IN THE
HEARING ROOM THAT WOULD LIKE TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT. C. NINE WILL
MOVE TO THE PHONE LINES PHONE
OPERATOR SUPPORT ON AB TWENTY
EIGHT SIXTY THREE. BUT SUPPORT
FOR TWENTY EIGHT SIXTY THREE
PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN. ZERO ONE
ZERO. NO ONE HAS QUEUED UP AT
THIS POINT A REMOVED OPPOSITION
IS THERE ANYONE IN THE HEARING
ROOM THAT WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION. OSCAR SORIANO I
OPPOSE THIS BILL AND I HOPE ALL
MY PRO DEMOCRATS DO THE SAME.
MAX GRAVELY BAPTIST CHURCH
LIBERTY LIFE CENTER AYE OPPOSED
THE BILL IT CAN BE DONE IN THE
PRIVATE SECTOR. CHEYENNE KENNY I
OPPOSE THIS BILL. LARA- I OPPOSE
THIS BILL. FRANEKER OPPOSE AB
TWENTY EIGHT SIXTY THREE.
ELIZABETH KENNY I OPPOSE THIS
BILL. THEY KNOW OTHERS WILL MOVE
TO THE PHONE LINE OPPOSITION ON
AB TWENTY SIXTY THREE. GIVE
OPPOSITION TO TWENTY EIGHT SIXTY
THREE PRESS ONE ZERO NINE ONE
FIVE- YOU ARE OPEN PLEASE
IDENTIFY YOURSELF. YES HI THIS
IS FROM A LARGE REPRESENTATIVES
TO RATHER EMPTY ASSIGNMENT AND
WE ARE STRONG OPPOSITION. AND
THIS BILL THANK YOU. NINE EIGHT
NINE YOU ARE OPEN PLEASE
IDENTIFY YOURSELF. I OPPOSE AB
TWENTY EIGHT SIXTY THREE STOP
STEALING OUR MONEY. WE HAVE ONE
MORE LINE ONE MOMENT. NINE ONE
THREE TWO YEAR OPEN PLEASE
IDENTIFY YOURSELF. HELLO MY NAME
IS VICTORIES MENDOZA AND
CONGRESS AND COUNTY AND I UPON
THIS BILL. NINE ONE FIVE SIX
ZERO COULD PLEASE IDENTIFY
YOURSELF. I WANT SIX TO YOUR
OPEN PLEASE IDENTIFY YOURSELF. I
OPPOSE THE BILL IT'S HORRIFIC.
NINE SIXTY FOR YOUR OPEN PLEASE
IDENTIFY YOURSELF. YES MY ALEJO
OPEN CONTAMINATE A COUNTY AND I
OPPOSE AB TWENTY EIGHT THREE.
WHAT OPERATOR THIS CONCLUDES THE
TESTIMONY ONLINE. ESTABLECE QUE
WILL BRING BACK TO THE COMMITTEE
NO COMMENTS FROM THE COMMITTEE
THIS IS ON THE B. ROLL CALL.
REGULATIONS ON YOUR FIRST BILL
THANK YOU THANK YOU FOR ALL
ENGAGE WHETHER THEY SUPPORT
OPPOSED. IF THAT CONCLUDES THE
REGULAR ORDER BILLS FROM THE TO
BE HEARD TODAY. WE APPRECIATE
THE AUTHORS AND THEIR
PRESENTATIONS WE LOVE LIKE TO.
MOVED TO OUR GENERAL PUBLIC
COMMENT SECTION WHERE WE WOULD
LIKE TO OPEN UP- THE HEARING TO
COMMENTS BY MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC ON ANY BILLS NOT
PRESENTED TO THE COMMITTEE
TODAY- PLEASE BE SURE TO LIMIT
YOUR COMMENTS TO YOUR NAME
ORGANIZATION IF ANY AND YOUR
POSITION ON THE BILL. IF THERE
IS ANYONE IN THE HEARING ROOM
WHO WOULD LIKE TO STATE THEIR
POSITION ON A BILL PLEASE
APPROACH THE MICROPHONE. AND WE
WILL HEAR THAT THIS IS ALL ON
BILLS THAT WERE EITHER CONSENT
OR ON SUSPENSE. MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS SEPARATIST REPRESENTING
GUNNERS CALIFORNIA. WE WANT TO
REGISTER A STRONG OPPOSITION TO
AB. FIFTY NINETY FOUR BY
CEMENTING THANK YOU. HELLO MY
NAME IS DENISE ANGULAR CO
FOUNDER FREEDOM ANGELS AND
REPRESENTATIVE OF LUCK SET AND
WE ARE IN OPPOSITION OF AB TWO
TWO TWO THREE. TARA THORNTON CO
FOUNDER FREEDOM ANGELS AND WE
ARE IN STRONG OPPOSITION TO AB
TWO TWO TWO THREE. JULIE'S GILES
WITH TODAY WAS RELEASED ON YOU
TUBE AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE AB
TWO TWO TWO THREE. RACHEL GATES
PRO CHOICE STRONGLY OPPOSE AB
TWO TWO TWO THREE. ELIZABETH
KENNY FROM OAKLAND CALIFORNIA
REPRESENTING THE BAN HAMMER LOCK
AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE AB. TWO
TWO TWO THREE. HI MY NAME IS
VANESSA SANTOS AND I AM STRONGLY
OPPOSED AB TWO TWO TWO THREE.
KATIE SCOTT MEN AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSE AB TWO TWO TWO THREE.
FRANEKER SULLIVAN AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSE AB TWO TWO TWO THREE. SHY
AND KENNY I STRONGLY OPPOSE AB
TWO TWO TWO THREE. LAUREN THE
BILL I WOULD- I STRONGLY OPPOSE
THIS BILL. DIANA HIU CAN I
STRONGLY OPPOSE AB TWO TWO TWO
THREE. ZERO J. S. I STRONGLY
OPPOSE AB TWENTY TWO TWENTY
THREE. MY NAME IS LEXI JASPER
AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE AB TWO TWO
TWO THREE. MY NAME IS SUSAN
AREN'T ALL I'M AN ATTORNEY WITH
THE RIGHT TO LIFE LEAGUE WE
STRONGLY SUPPOSED OPPOSE AB
TWENTY TWO TWENTY THREE AND ALSO
S. B. TWENTY FIVE EIGHTY SIX
THANK YOU. MY NAME IS ERIN
JASPER WITH LIBERTY LIFE CENTER
LIBERTY BAPTIST ACADEMY AS WELL
AS JASPER PREPARATORY ACADEMY%
AND I AM OPPOSED TO AB TWENTY
TWO TWENTY THREE. MAX GRAVES
LIBERTY BAPTIST CHURCH LIBERTY
LIFE CENTER I STRONGLY OPPOSE AB
TWENTY TWO TWENTY THREE HOW LONG
WILL YOU JUDGE UNJUSTLY. AND
GIVE FAVORS AS A WICKED MAN
ORGANIZATION TURNING RIGHT
PLEASE NAMES I'VE GIVEN THE
RULES IF YOU CAN'T ABIDE BY THEM
THEN WE'RE GOING TO HAVE TO ASK
YOU TO EXCUSE YOURSELF FROM THE
RIVER. THE HEARING ROOM. BUT
MORNING PASTOR TIM BENEFIELD
CORNERSTONE BAPTIST CHURCH IN
MODESTO AND ALSO REPRESENTING
TAKE A STAND STANISLAUS. AND WE
STRONGLY OPPOSE AB TWO TWO TWO
THREE. LARRY **** PASTOR FIRST
BAPTIST CHURCH- PRINCIPAL AND
PINER POINT CHRISTIAN ACADEMY I
STAND WITH THE MAJORITY OF
VOICES AGAINST AB. TWENTY TWO
TWENTY THREE. MOSTLY GRAVES
LIBERTY BAPTIST CHURCH IN
LIBERTY BAPTIST LIFE ACADEMY AND
LIBERTY LIFE CENTER I STRONGLY
OPPOSE AB TWENTY TWO TWENTY
THREE. MAX GRACE PASTOR LIBERTY
BAPTIST CHURCH REPRESENTING ALSO
AS DIRECTOR OF LIVE REAL LIFE
CENTER WOULD YOU CALIFORNIA AND
I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS WE COULD
LEGISLATION OF AB TWENTY TWO
TWENTY THREE RIGHTEOUSNESS
EXALTS A NATION. AND PROCESSING
THEM ORGANIZATION AGAIN PLEASE.
THE PROPOSAL RESPECT THE SPEECH
. OSCAR SORIANO AND AYE OPPOSE
THIS BILL. I WOULD RAISE GRAVES
AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE AB TWO TWO
TWO THREE. I'M SHAUNA WILLIAMS
WITH COVERAGE CHAPEL CHURCH AND
I'M RODDICK ORANGE COUNTY
CALIFORNIA AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE
TWENTY TWO TWENTY THREE. MISTER
JAMES COOK LIGHTHOUSE BAPTIST
CHURCH CONCORD CALIFORNIA AND-
PROJECT TRUCE I STRONGLY OPPOSE
AB TWENTY TWO TWENTY THREE GOD
IS WATCHING YOU. MY NAME'S CAN
COOK AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE
TWENTY TWO TWENTY THREE. LAUREN
LOW BROUGH AYE OPPOSED TWENTY TO
TWENTY THREE. THANK YOU WILL
MOVE TO THE PHONE LINES
OPERATORS ARE ANYONE ON THE
PHONE LINE TO HAVE PUBLIC
COMMENT ON BILLS THAT WERE. NOT
PRESENT ON TODAY. I YES LITE
WANTED YOUR OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD
. THIS IS GABRIELLE INGRAM
FOUNDER STAND AT SACRAMENTO
COUNTY CALLING ABOUT AB. TWO TWO
TWO TWO THREE WE OPPOSE THIS
BILL. NINE ONE ONE FOR YOUR
GROUP PLEASE GO AHEAD. ONE ONE
FOR YOUR OPEN. ONE OH THREE OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THREE HUNDRED
WHO NOT ONLY CAN. HELLO. YES GO
AHEAD PLEASE. THREE I COULD DO
NOT AND I OPPOSE A. B. TWENTY
TWO TWENTY THREE. NINE ONE ONE
FIVE YEAR OPEN PLEASE IDENTIFY
SO. SH MY NAME IS AN QUE IN
SACRAMENTO CALIFORNIA I STRONGLY
OPPOSE AB. TWENTY TWO TWENTY
THREE. MY TWELVE YEAR OVER BY
THAT NUMBER BUT ALSO THE DEVICE
UP TO DANIEL ELECTED IN
REPRESENTS THOUSANDS OF LATINOS
AND WE'RE ASKING YOU TO STOP
USING MINORITIES IN USE FOR YOU
ARE GENERALLY VERY STRONGLY
OPPOSE AB. TWO TWO TWO THREE
THANK. FIVE ONE FIVE ZERO YOUR
OPEN PLEASE IDENTIFY YOURSELF.
YES HI THIS IS TRENT LOTT. ALL
REPRESENTING DAVID BRADLEY BURKE
ORGANIZATION AND- PASHA WILLIAMS
AND WE ARE IN THE STRONG
OPPOSITION- THIS IS A FIVE BILL
AB TWO TWO TWO THREE. ONE ONE
FIVE SIX ZERO PLEASE IDENTIFY
YOURSELF. HI MY NAME IS LYNETTE
GONZALEZ AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE
AB TWO TWO TWO THREE THANK YOU.
OWNER OPERATOR THE SECOND CLUE
THE PUBLIC COMMENT ON ON
FORMALLY. NO WE HAVE ONE THAT
WHAT FIVE NINE YOU'RE OPEN. ONE
SIX ONE YOUR OPEN PLEASE
IDENTIFY YOURSELF. COTTMAN I
OPPOSE AB. THREE TWO TWO THREE.
ONE SIX FIVE YEAR OPEN THREE
SEVEN FIVE SO. MY NAME IS DR
LISA LINDSEY AND I OPPOSE BILL
TWO TWO TWO THREE. ONE SIX SIX
ZERO COULD PLEASE IDENTIFY TELL
- GOOD MORNING SURE MEMBERS CAN
NOT SURE WHAT THE LOS ANGELES
COUNTY OFF ASIAN OR AB ONE SIX
SIX SEVEN COOPER EIGHTEEN SIXTY
EIGHT OF THE TRADERS AND AB
EIGHTEEN TWENTY SEVEN
QUIRK-SILVA THANK YOU. ONE FOUR
SIX ZERO COULD PLEASE IDENTIFY
YOURSELF. MY NAME IS TINA GOOD
HERE IT'S FROM STAMINA DINO
COUNTY AND I OPPOSE AB TWO TWO
TWO THREE. ONE SIX SEVEN YOUR
OPEN PLEASE IDENTIFY YOURSELF.
GOOD MORNING JERRY NUMBERED
MADELINE COOPERMAN NIELSEN MARK
MARK WOULD LIKE TO REGISTER ON
AB SEVENTEEN CAN BE THIRTY AND
AB TWENTY FIVE SEVENTY TWO ON
BEHALF OF YELLOW COUNTY AND AB
TWENTY TWO SIXTY THREE ON BEHALF
THE ASSOCIATED BUILDERS AND
CONTRACTORS OF CALIFORNIA. THANK
YOU KNOW. ONE SIX NINE YEAR OPEN
PLEASE IDENTIFY YOURSELF. GOOD
MORNING CHEERING MEMBERS MEANING
THESE CHANNEL THREE ON BEHALF OF
TAKEN IN SANTA CLARA WE ARE IN
STRONG OPPOSITION TO THAT THE
ASSEMBLY BELL TWENTY TWO TWENTY
THREE THANK YOU. ONE SEVEN ONE
YOUR OPEN PLEASE IDENTIFY
YOURSELF. GOOD MORNING MY NAME
IS DANIEL RODRIGUEZ CALLING ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA STUDENT
AID COMMISSION IN STRONG SUPPORT
OF AB TWO TWO EIGHT SIX BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER IRWIN AND AB TWO
ZERO ZERO FOUR BY CRISTINA
GARCIA WHICH WOULD HURT BUT WAS
HAVING TROUBLE WITH THE LINE
BUT- TO BILLS FOR TODAY. THANK
YOU. ONE SEVEN EIGHT ZERO PLEASE
IDENTIFY YOURSELF. IN A HERALD
FROM SACRAMENTO COUNTY WHO WAS
THE MOST MISGUIDED BY AN
ABORTION I STRONGLY OPPOSE AB
TWO TWO TWO THREE. MY NINETEEN
YEAR OPENED PLEASE IDENTIFY OF.
HI KATHLEEN THOMAS AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE AB TWO TWO TWO
THREE. NINE TWENTY SIX EUROPA
PLEASE IDENTIFY THE- HI MY NAME
IS YVETTE JENKINS AND I'M FROM
CALIFORNIA AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE
AB TWENTY TWO TWENTY THREE AND I
URGE YOU TO PLEASE DON'T KNOW.
I'M THIRTY TWO YEAR OPEN PLEASE
IDENTIFY YOURSELF. IS THERE ARE
QUITE A ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA NURSING RIGHT BECAUSE
YOU SHOULD AND PRO CHOICE
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT. AND.
EIGHTY TO TWO TO THREE. NINE ONE
SIX ZERO COULD PLEASE IDENTIFY
YOURSELF. ON BEHALF OF THE FIJI
U. S. DETERRENT UNITED AND WE
STRONGLY OPPOSE AB TWO TWO TWO
THREE. FIVE ONE FIVE FIVE EURO
COULD PLEASE IDENTIFY SO. MY
NAME IS JONATHAN CAMERINO AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE AB T. TWO P.
THREE. NINE ONE EIGHTY NINE YOUR
OPEN PLEASE IDENTIFY SO. THIS IS
TRICIA CHAPARRAL CALLING FROM
FOR FRANCISCO CALIFORNIA
STRONGLY OPPOSED EIGHTY. NINE
LINE SIXTY YEAR OPEN PLEASE
IDENTIFY YOURSELF. HI MY NAME IS
MARINA MEDICAL I'M CALLING ON
BEHALF OF CALIFORNIA PARENTS
UNITED AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE AB. TWO TWO TWO THREE. MY FIFTY
FOUR YEAR OPEN PLEASE IDENTIFY
YOURSELF. YOUR TURN MEMBER
SOPHIA TOLLI SHANTI HALF OF LA
TWENTY EIGHT IN STRONG SUPPORT
SPONSORED EIGHTY TWENTY SEVEN
FORTY SEVEN THANK YOU.
TWENTY FOUR YEAR OLD COULD
PLEASE IDENTIFY. GOOD AFTERNOON
MY NAME IS KENNETH PAULO I'M IN
ABOUT THE- WITH LEX IT- I
REPRESENT OVER HALF A MILLION
LATINOS AND HISPANICS IN
AMERICA- STOP TRYING TO KILL OUR
PEOPLE I AM STRONGLY IN
OPPOSITION OF AB TWENTY TWO
TWENTY THREE. FIVE ONE SEVENTY
YEAR OPEN PLEASE IDENTIFY
YOURSELF. YEAH MY NAM IS SAMUEL
HIDE FROM THE COALITION OF UNDER
NAME TRANSMUTE AND THE PATERNITY
OF ANGRY DAY STUDENTS AND WE
STRONGLY OPPOSE BILL TWO TWO TWO
THREE. NINE FIFTY NINE YEAR OLD
COULD PLEASE IDENTIFY YOURSELF.
ROBIN WAS ELECTED PRESIDENT OF
THE LARGE AT THE MOMENT I HAVE
GOT AND WE STRONGLY OPPOSE A. B.
CONTROL. LINE ONE A FORTY FOUR
I'M SORRY ONE FORTY FIVE YOUR
OPEN PLEASE IDENTIFY. HI MY NAME
IS AMBER CALTRAIN CALLING FROM
RAINFALL CALIFORNIA I AM
STRONGLY OPPOSED BEING AB. TWO
TWO TWO THREE. ONE FORTY YEAR
OLD INTRIGUED BY THEM FOR YOU SO
. HELLO MY NAME IS MELISSA
FARIAS. I AM FROM RIVERSIDE
COUNTY CALIFORNIA AMBASSADOR OF
ALEXEI AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE.
EIGHTY TWO TWO TWO THREE. NINE
ONE EIGHT SEVEN YOUR OPEN PLEASE
IDENTIFY YOURSELF. WELL ONE
EIGHT WHEN YOU'RE OPEN. IN A
PARK. OKAY ADAM UNTENABLE AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE. EIGHTY TWO
EIGHTY THREE. MIKE SIXTY THREE
OPEN PLEASE IDENTIFY YOURSELF.
YEAH MICHAEL BRYAN AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE AB TWO TWO TWO
THREE. I WON NINETY I'M SORRY
ONE EIGHT TWO YOUR OPENED PLEASE
IDENTIFY YOURSELF. ONE MOMENT.
AND ONE NINE FIVE EURO COULD
PLEASE IDENTIFY YOURSELF. HELLO
MY NAME IS ELIANA HONEY CUTS I
AM CALLING ON BEHALF OF THE
LOTUS BUT I FOUNDATION AND
STRONG SUPPORT OF BOTH THE BILLS
AB TWENTY THIRTY AND A. B.
TWENTY FOUR NINETY FOUR AND- AB
TWENTY THIRTY IS AN ARAMBULA AB
TWENTY FOUR NINETY FOUR THE
SILENCE STILL- I'M HOPING. WE
CAN TAKE SUPPORT FOR THAT- EXIT
OKAY TO CONTINUE TO CALL IN FOR
THAT. THIS IS JUST PUBLIC
COMMENT OF NAME ORGANIZATION AND
YOUR POSITION ON THE BILL. OKAY
SO ALL OTHER BILLS ARE FINE SO
WE CAN CONTINUE TO CALL IN FOR A
BI TWENTY THIRTEEN EIGHTY TWENTY
FOUR NINETY FOUR CORRECT. THIS
IS THE PUBLIC COMMENT THIS IS
WERE RUINED THE- THIS HEARING
TODAY SO IF YOU'RE CALLING RIGHT
AT THIS MOMENT TO REGISTER YOUR
SUPPORT AND WE ARE KNOWLEDGE IN
THAT SUPPORT ON THE BILL'S IT'S
REALISTIC. PERFECT THANK YOU SO
MUCH THANK YOU. FIVE ONE SIX
EIGHT YOUR OPEN PLEASE THAT THE
FISA. HI THIS IS A RENDON AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE AB TWO TWO TWO
THREE IF THE WOULD GET INTO
MONARCH. LINE ONE A TWO YEAR
OPEN PLEASE IDENTIFY YOURSELF.
HELLO HI MY NAME IS BIG BANG HIM
FROM THE BLESSING CHURCH OF
WHILE NOT CALIFORNIA AND I WE
OPPOSE AB TWENTY TWO TWENTY
THREE. THANK YOU. AN ALLY.
NINETY SEVEN. I NINETY SEVEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. LINE. EIGHTY
NINE. AB TWO TWO TWO THREE IS
EVIL TRASHED. OPPOSE. WHY.
NINETY HELLO. WE CAN HEAR YOU
OKAY THANK YOU MY NAME IS
PANDORA NICHOLAS I'M IN LINCOLN
CLASSIC COUNTY I'M WITH THE
CHURCH OF GLAD TIDINGS IN YUBA
CITY. I'M HOPING MY INFANT SON
AND I VERY STRONGLY OPPOSE AB
TWENTY TWO TWENTY THREE. LINE
SIXTY FOUR. HI THIS IS MARY
HOLDEN FROM TERMINAL COUNTY AND
I STRONGLY OPPOSED AB TWO TWO TO
THREE AND A. B. TWO FIVE EIGHTY
SIX. THANK YOU. LINE. EIGHTY
EIGHT. HI MY NAME IS A DEER THAT
LEON I AM SUPPORTING- LEXINGTON
OTHER LATINOS IN CALIFORNIA AND
I STRONGLY OPPOSE AB TWENTY TWO
TWENTY THREE. LINE. EIGHTY FIVE.
HI THIS IS RACHEL CAN WHERE DOES
NOT MAKE YOU A DEEPER AND TO BE
. EIGHT EIGHT CUTE. TO THREE.
LINE EIGHTY TWO. GOOD MORNING
BEAUTIFUL PEOPLE ON BEHALF OF
ROCKER CHURCH AND CARRIED HER
FIGHT THOUGH YEAH AND LYFT
MATTERS MANY MILITARY THE KOBE
AND FROM FULLER COUNTY AND WE
ARE IN STRONG VIOLENT OBELISK
OPPOSITION TO AB. TWENTY TWO
TWENTY THREE THANK YOU SIR
BLESSINGS ON YOUR DAY. LINE AT
ONE NINETY SEVEN. HI THIS IS
CYNTHIA MORENO I'M CALLING THE
BLACK DAUGHTERS AND MOTHERS
HIGHLY OPPOSE EACH YEAR TWO TO
THREE A BILL THAT LEGALIZES
MURDER THANK YOU. LINE. FORTY
ONE. LINE FORTY ONE YEAR MIKE IS
OPEN. WINE TWO HUNDRED FIVE. HI
CAN YOU HEAR ME. YES WE CAN
ARGUE. HELLO WE ARE NOT THANK
YOU I'M THREE NOT COULD NOT I AM
A REGISTERED NURSE I ALSO ATTEND
CALVARY CHAPEL CHINO HILLS AND I
VERY VERY STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS
BILL THANK YOU. BLINDED TWO
HUNDRED THREE. MR HEARING
MEMBERS OF THE ASSEMBLY SHANTI
PATH. L. A. TWENTY EIGHT STRONG
SUPPORT MONSTER OF EIGHTY TWENTY
SEVEN FORTY SEVEN THANK YOU.
WIND TO TEN. HI MY NAME IS
CHRISTINA MCKINNEY I AM A NURSE
AND SAMPOERNA DINO AND RIVERSIDE
COUNTIES AND I OPPOSE AB TWO TWO
TWO THREE THANK YOU SO MUCH.
LINE A ONE HUNDRED FOUR. LINE
ONE HUNDRED FOR YOUR MIKE IS
OPEN. YOU HEAR ME. YES WE CAN
AREA. I SUPPORT THAT DIFFICULT A
LITTLE FAST FROM THE LOADING
WHAT THE CONDITION AND I A
FAMILY SUPPORT DAY TWENTY THIRTY
AND EVERY PASSAGE REPRESENTING
MY COMMUNITY. AND I SUPPORTING
Q. R. AB- AB I AM TWENTY FOUR.
NINETY FOUR AND WHEN HE
REPRESENTING MY COMMUNITY THE
STRONGEST ACCORDING TO. LINE A.
FIFTY ONE. LINE FIFTY ONE YEAR
MIKE IS OPEN. HELLO HELLO WE CAN
AREA. HELLO HELLO YOUR MAKE IT
OPEN. MY NAME IS HELENA BRIAN
AND AYE OPPOSED TO TWO TO THREE
. CAN'T. ONE THIRTY ONE. LINE
ONE THIRTY ONE YEAR MIKE IS OPEN. HI GOOD MORNING MAINTAINED AND
I SUPPORT AB TWENTY SB THREE
THIRTY AND EIGHTY. TWENTY FOUR
NINETY FOUR. LINE ONE FORTY.
SHARE A MEMORY MY NAME IS DENISE
AND I'M CALLING FROM TULARE
COUNTY I USED SUPPORT AB TWENTY
FOUR NINETY FOUR AND ALSO A. B.
TWENTY THIRTY THANK YOU. WIND OF. ONE HUNDRED ELEVEN. GOOD
MORNING MY NAME EXTRACTING
ANALYST LATELY SERVICES FOR
PRINT HAS WITH CHILDREN CALLING
IN STRONG SUPPORT OF AB. TWENTY
SEVENTEEN ONE AB. TWENTY FOUR
SEVENTEEN EIGHTEEN SEVEN
SEVENTEEN AND. EIGHTEEN TWENTY
EIGHT THANK YOU. WHY NOT. ONE
EIGHTY SIX- PASTOR BRANDON
CAMPBELL A IN THE CALIFORNIA
CAPITAL CONNECTION FOR PASSED IN
BAPTIST CHURCHES UP AND DOWN THE
COAST OF CALIFORNIA IN STRONG
OPPOSITION OF AB. TWO TO THREE.
ALIGNMENT. NINETY SEVEN. LINE
NINETY SEVEN YEAR MIKE IS OPEN.
LINE IT A. HELLO HELLO WE CAN
HEAR YOU. MIDDLE TO TWO TO THREE
MORE MODEL THERE'S NO ONE ALL IS
MANDA. I INTO TWENTY. HI MY NAME
IS APRIL WILL BE FROM A RECITE
COUNTY A MOTHER OF Q. I'VE HAD
THREE MISCARRIAGES AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE AB TWO TWO TWO
THREE. LINE ONE SIXTY FOUR. THIS
IS OUT OF THE MARKET SO THAT THE
LOTUS WHAT THE FOUNDATION. I
STRONGLY. EIGHT TWENTY. ANY TWO
FOR NOW. FOUR LINE A. FORTY ONE.
LINE FORTY ONE YEAR MIKE IS OPEN
FOR ALL. FIND A ONE NINETY FOUR
. RIGHT THIS IS JUST OUR CAT
REPRESENTING MEDINA COUNTY AND-
SPECIFICALLY ASSEMBLY DISTRICT
FORTY ONE AYE OPPOSE AB TWO TWO
TWO THREE I A BOAT POSE A. B.
EIGHTY FIVE EIGHTY SIX AND
TWENTY THREE TWENTY AND EVERY
OTHER SINGLE ABORTION REFINEMENT
BUT YOU GUYS ARE TRYING TO GET
THROUGH. LINE ONE HUNDRED FOUR.
LINE ONE HUNDRED FOR YOUR MIKE
IS OPEN. AND IT WE HAVE NO
FURTHER COMMENT AT THIS TIME.
THANK YOU- THAT NAT WILL
CONCLUDE OUR PUBLIC COMMENT FOR
TODAY BEFORE WE ADJOURN THE
MEETING- I NEED TO- CORRECT-
VOTE ON AB TWENTY SEVEN TWENTY
EIGHT SMITH. ARE WE SHOULD HAVE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WEBER THING
OFFER NOT VOTING. OKAY I
CONCLUDES OUR BUSINESS FOR TODAY.